You've mentioned platonic kissing. I think I did mention that.
Hi. I love platonic kissing. Good to know. This is not a thing.
Platonic like kissing. At least with you're making out. That's
not a thing. Platonic kissing is not a thing. That's some Britney
Simon [__] Oh, I just shower with my friends and
it's not Shut up. That's wrong. You're wrong. You're wrong. You're
wrong. You're wrong.
So, we have our first
review in a long time. Okay, something on the level of the Minecraft
reviews that we started this stream with. Okay, something in
the Katybugs stratosphere of reviews. All right, we have Shay,
who is a speedrunner, plays Undertale and Delta Rune, they had
a bunch of allegations drop on them recently. Okay, a ton a ton.
Anyway, okay, what am I looking for? Oh, we're going to do the
Shay thing. Yes, so this Shay person, they're a speedrunner.
They're very popular. 488,000 viewers or subscribers. Let's look
at some of their videos. 252, 293, 135, 147, 222, like a whole
bunch of >> This is what they look like. >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> I can fix. >> This is them.
Okay. And this guy had a whole bunch of allegations drop. Now,
I haven't gone into it very much. I don't know what the allegations
are. I do know that it is funny. I've been told it's funny by
a couple people,
and I'm very interested. All right.
very very very interested. Okay, so first of all, the first thing
we have
is basically a friend of theirs who went live
or possibly just posted a video. I'm not sure. Somebody named
Violet Bunny. Okay, Violet Bunny. I Wow. Violet Violet Bunny.
Okay, Violet Bunny. It looked
Yep.
Do not PSA.
Do not interact with Shay.
PSA, do not interact with Shay. So, they step out ahead of things
and they're going to make some comments.
This looks like somebody I know and I I'm trying to think of
like who it is. If it's like a streamer or something,
who is it? Who is it? Who is it? Who is it? Oh, come on. The
room is clean, so I'm inclined to believe this is a ripoff. The
ones you can't trust are the ROM maxers. The one you can trust,
you mean? are the rot maxers. Female wick. No, not female wick.
No, not tilda switting in a fat suit. Not pyroynical either.
It's like some I'm Dude, it's not. It's not. No, no, no, no.
You guys are getting it all wrong. There's like I thought maybe
Tommen from Game of Thrones in a wig, but I don't think so. We'll
just have to keep going. I'll never figure it out. Oh, it's muted.
I muted it. I'm recording this on November 18th of 2025.
>> If you're seeing this, there has been an exposure document
released about Sheay, who you might know as the popular Undertale
series content creator. They have done completely reprehensible
things to their friends and loved ones, and many people that
I know have been affected by their horrible actions.
Okay, so many bad things, many people affected.
These are >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Female Ryan Beard is way closer than anything so far.
Okay. Yes. Female Ryan Beard's way closer than anything else
so far. >> Chronicled in a document posted in the description.
Just a fair warning.
>> Oh, hold on. Document posted in the description. What?
What? I have these docs, by the way.
Oh my goodness. It's
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Okay. Okay. Main. So, this is all
tabbed out, but we will go through this. Okay, there's there's
many allegations. This is just the intro. >> For anyone
that goes to read it, it accounts for events such as
assault,
abuse,
ver. Okay, assault is something with these people. A lot of the
time, I got to pause the music for just a second. With a lot
of these allegations sometimes when it doesn't get up to like
a tangible like oh salt type of allegation, man, you cannot trust
these people on words. On words sometimes it's really but they
never get it right. All right. They just never ever ever get
it right.
It seems like they always like they overblow certain things,
they underplay certain things, but if it if there's actual assault
allegations, then we we're cooking with gas. All right. >> Verbal
abuse, grooming,
and a number of other horrible
So, I'm just laying that out for anyone that is sensitive to
those kinds of things.
I have been in the know about these actions for the past uh I
want to say uh
hours.
And uh before learning about this uh they were someone that I
considered a
>> Damn. and
reading everyone's testimonies
and the events that were shown in the document. I man I have
nothing. Alien mode, thank you for the 18 months. I am not sure
what exactly. I don't want to be rude. Okay. I really don't want
to be rude. I don't know what to say other than I don't want
to be rude. This is this is a male to female transerson, right?
Am I wrong? This is It seems very obvious, but maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe this is a biological trans person. Sorry,
I meant a biological female. Maybe it's just a biological female.
Okay, I just I gota I got to I got to know. Why do you do this?
I
This is rough.
I It's just rough. Okay, I'm sorry. It's just rough. I'm going
to >> how they were affected by Sheay's
has just completely shattered my trust. It is horrific.
which is the whole reason why I'm making this video. Because
their horrible actions deserve to be exposed to the world to
see, so that everyone in this community can see them for the
true scum that they are.
Now, regarding what I plan on doing, uh, since you might be aware,
every the way this person talks, they didn't get the right speech
therapy. They sound like they're about to cry, but I don't think
they're about to cry. You could believe they're about to cry
because of because of the way they're like
annunciating with like the breaths the the the intakes of breaths,
but like I think they just they're trying to speak with a more
female affectation
and they're failing and they just sound like they're about to
cry a lot of the time. Now, regarding what the true scum that
they are. Now, regarding what I plan on doing, uh, since you
might be aware that I put a couple of references to Shay in Delta
Traveler,
as of recording this, I have already released a patch for the
game for all platforms. Uh, that removes all references to this
person.
Oh, wait. Is this This isn't the developer of the game that she
speedruns, is it? No. Delta Rune is the game she speedruns or
they speedrun,
>> right? Delta Rune.
Delta Rune, not Delta Traveler, whatever the [__]
As well as generally removing uh references to other content
creators.
Uh you likely will not see any other YouTuber references in my
games going forward.
It's proven time and time again that some people just do not
know how to handle immense fame and notoriety like what Sheay
got. There have been numerous incidents
like this one where they let the power get into their heads and
they just assume that they can do whatever the they want. This
is not the first
that I've experienced this kind of
by someone popular that I knew. It's not even the first in this
community.
And frankly, I'm just tired of being burned
Wait, I could believe that. I listen, there's something insidious
about the Undertale community. If you know if you know anything
about Pirate Software, that's what his game was supposed to be,
right? A spiritual success successor to Undertale. Supposed to
be very Undertale coded, right? There's something insidious about
Undertale as a video game. and the people who become obsessed
with it. And I don't know what it is.
It is it just it invites like the weirdest people
somehow.
I don't know what it is. I I can't explain it. It's very deviant
Same with FNAF. Well, FNAF's liked by kids. I don't think kids
like Undertale in the same way that they like FNAF. >> Big
figures that turn out to be up
And I guess if that means my success online is hampered, then
that has then that's how it's supposed to be
because I'm
sick of this.
And I have a little personal message to Shay who might be watching
this assuming they haven't bunkered after everything has crumbled
around them.
P is that saying assuming they haven't killed themselves yet?
That's what that that's what that means, right? That's just a
coded way of saying assume they haven't killed themselves yet.
Bunkered in the bunker. Something like that. >> Do not
speak to me ever again. You've >> d this person these people
can't be serious.
They actually can't be serious. And like it is just funny. I'm
sorry.
There's like a there's like a hierarchy of things going on here
that I I'm like actually a bigot. I'm sorry. You cannot be a
male to female trans person who puts like no effort into passing
and just like dyes your hair and then get very serious and like
try to get soy in the camera. This doesn't work. You are literally
just a meme in and of yourself. You are just an automatic meme
>> They haven't bunkered after everything has crumbled
around them.
>> Um, never speak to me ever again. Never. Never ever
speak to me ever again.
Do not speak to me ever again. You vile piece of [__]
You have hurt so many people in such despicable ways that
it's
dude. ALSO, WHY DON'T YOU cut that,
bro? In such despicable ways
that
it's
Is this like Tourette's?
What is happening
>> in such despicable ways is
what is the pause? What is the what is happening to like stop
and swallow in the middle of the sentence like that? Just reshoot.
>> It is unforgivable
and honestly thinking back having taken all of this.
>> Okay, this feels like bullying. If this person said
they were a victim, I would not bully them like this. Okay, this
person said they were a victim. They just found out about the
allegations. They can take it. If it was like one of the victims
of this person, I'd probably go a little easier. Okay. >> It's
very obvious why you never spoke to me very much. And that's
because I wasn't exploitable like the victims you
>> This guy, this person
Oh, I'm such a
Okay, this person got what we like to call the Stardust Past.
Okay, the Stardust Pass. She wasn't predated on by the total
degenerate that she knew.
You should get the Stardust Pass. Okay,
>> go yourself.
Also, uh if you feel remorseful for your actions, quote unquote,
uh feel free to send me a refund on the Sha plushies I bought
to support you and also all the ad revenue for the Delta Traveler
videos you made. I'll go ahead and link my co
Dude, no way. Why don't you Why don't you actually pay me for
all the free publicity you've given my game? You should pay me
for that free publicity that you gave my game in the description
just for you. >> That's crazy.
Okay, so anyway, that's that's how we start off with this. Let's
find some comfy music to get into it, okay? Cuz we've got a whole
doc, we've got docs, we've got tweets, we've got everything.
link to the original tweet. Now, the tweet is linked after the
dock. What the doc is
just a link to the tweet. Okay. So, Willie J. Willie Jay tweets
out Undertale leaderboard moderator, Stratfinder, former runner.
Content warning: assaults, harassment, grooming, abusive. While
in the community, Shay has committed reprehensible acts, including
grooming multiple fans and assaulting their now exartner. They're
an active danger to the community. Please read.
Here we are doing some Google Doc stuff. Some Google Doc reading
like the old days. Let's get the magnifying glass out and see
what we got here. Okay,
preface.
We a collective group of Shea's victims and former friends accuse
Sheay of actions including but not limited to assault, harassment,
grooming, orbiting fans until they're of legal age, coercion,
and abuse. We are releasing this document because we feel that
she's actions pose a present and extreme safety risk to the community
such that people need to be aware to protect themselves. In this
document, you will find a collection of our stories, statements,
and supporting evidence to these accusations. Sheay himself has
already admitted to the actions detailed in the testimonies from
anonymous number one, Azura F, anonymous number three, and Willie
J. Willie J to the victims themselves in private.
Okay. So, wait. We have these private
We have these private acknowledgements,
We'll see. They say they say they've got all of these acknowledgements
written down. I don't know. We'll see. We'll
But this document contains testimonies of events that have taken
place as recently as the past week and traumatic events that
the victims are processing for the first time. While we recognize
the importance of timeliness and have done our best to compile
this document quickly, we've chosen to prioritize the safety
of the victims such that they can process what was done to them
without the needless cruelty of forcing them to tell their stories
to us, let alone to the public, before they were ready. Frankly,
even just the sheer amount of corroborating accounts that were
shared with us just over the past few days made it impossible
to release a statement that would be and remain sufficiently
comprehensive any sooner. We hope you can understand that no
amount of pressure to make a statement was going to force us
to jeopardize the well-being of the victims and that anything
but the full truth would be unfairly reductive to those to those
of us who wish to have our stories heard. We are not a professional
PR firm. We are a group of people who have been deeply hurt,
taken advantage of, abused, and betrayed.
Wait, I thought
collective group of Sha's victims and former friends. Okay.
We are are people with private lives that now have to contend
with sharing our negative experiences out to the public because
Sha's inappropriate because of Sha's inappropriate patterns of
behavior or because Shaya's inappropriate patterns of behavior
have
uh and worsened far beyond what constitutes drama. Ah well listen
everything constitutes drama. Okay? This is drama. We implore
you to read this document in full and humbly ask for your patience
and empathy as we bear our hearts to you. We ask that you do
not attempt to contact nor harass anyone mentioned in this document
regarding its contents and and that you do not attempt to identify
and or publish information that reflect the identities of the
victims that have chosen to remain anonymous. Do not treat this
document as an exhaustive list of all those affected. At minimum,
we can confirm there are more victims that have spoken to us
but have chosen not to tell their story publicly at this time.
Please respect their privacy until they wish to share and show
them grace and kindness when they do so. Thank you from all of
us for reading. Damn, it's
So, additional content. Wait, why is it additional context first?
Oh, additional context. Additional context needed to understand
the contents of this document can be found below. People who
have chosen to publish their testimonies anonymously have had
arbitrary names, colors, and numbers assigned. These are consistent
throughout all the text and screenshots. All sensors in black.
Dude, they systematized this. Damn. Many of these statements
will mention a trusted or vent discord channel. This refers to
channels in Sha's to the channels in Sha's server, frog family,
that those uh that only those with the idiot or moderator roles
have access to. The role idiot was typically given only to close
friends of Sheay and those who were close with many in the group.
It is important to note that much of the behavior described in
this document has been brought to Shea's attention repeatedly
as early as 2021 and as late as a week ago. This document was
created after multiple attempts to get them to change with no
result, even after those affected privately reached out to bring
it to Sha's attention.
The information gathered was collected in pieces from multiple
people who all initially believed they were these were isolated
incidents. It is only when those affected reached out to one
another that the true scope was realized.
Though this will be obvious based on the content shared here,
Shay has had no part in writing this document and has not seen
the vast majority of its content prior to it being shared with
the public in general, the general public.
Okay,
Star Smiley. Trigger warning, this document contains description
of salt.
Hi, I'm Star Smiley and for those who don't know, I've been Sha's
partner for the last 5 to 6 years. I've been living with them
since August 2025 and within the last week have moved back with
my parents. I'm going to outline the experiences I had during
this relationship. Starting with the most serious events. Most
of these interactions happened in real life when it was just
the two of us. There is an important part of this relationship
you need to understand going into all of this. I identify as
a and I'm not interested in doing anything with anyone. Jay was
the was aware of this and generally respected this throughout
the relationship.
I understand that they needed a outlet and agreed that they could
have contact with others. I did not request that they tell me
who it was or when it happened, but I will go into how it was
handled poorly. At the beginning of November 2025, Jay and I
were lounging on our bed in the main bedroom. We started cuddling
and suddenly they had laid a hand on my crotch and started rubbing
it without asking. This has never happened before and I froze.
But they did it they did it for a minute or so before saying,
"So you really don't feel anything, huh? That's crazy." before
pulling and before laughing and pulling away. I did not give
consent for them to do this, which makes it assault. I'm also
and I felt disrespected in my identity that they felt the need
to test whether I was a or not. As I mentioned previously, dude,
really?
Uh,
really? I What is he doing?
Just checking. Just wanted to make sure. Just quick test, guys.
Real quick test. Rub rub rub rub. Uh, really nothing. Okay. All
right. Moving on. Why?
Why? Why did this just click over? What?
Okay, we continue. As I mentioned previously,
I agreed that they could have contact with others and did not
want to specify that they had to tell me what when it happened
or who it was with. I did not expect them to be having this behavior
with nearly 20 people nearly constantly throughout the entire
relationship. Furthermore, they've reassured others that they
did in fact ask my permission for those specific encounters to
happen, which they did not. They were going off of the original
agreement which was at this point years old. Okay, this is stupid.
You can't say, "Okay, you you don't tell me about any of your
interactions and you do whatever you want and then I'm" and then
when they didn't tell you and they had a whole bunch of interactions,
which was a part of the agreement, you go, "Whoa, I didn't agree
to this.
I didn't Whoa, I didn't agree to this at
This this part is stupid." The assault serious. This part is
stupid to say like, "Oh, I agreed for an open relationship where
I don't get any details." Oh, wait, not like that. No, you said
no details. Anyway,
uh these people were led to believe Shay was telling me about
this when it happened and have said they would not participate
if they knew I didn't know. They would also intentionally invite
people over while I was I don't even think it's lying for him
to say this person knows about it, right? I really don't. We'll
see if they if they get into more context here,
but for him to just go, "Yeah, no, we have like a a like base
agreement."
I don't think that's weird. I don't think that's really lying.
They would also intentionally invite people over while I was
away from the house for the purpose of acting with them and again,
not tell me what happened while I was away.
I guess this could be annoying, right? But again, if you ask
for no details, that means no details. Why are we Why are we
changing it up after the fact? I want to note that when I also
Is this music loud? Feels a little loud.
Going down a little bit.
They would uh they would intentionally invite these people over.
I want to note that when I left the house with Shay to go back
to my parents, I did so in secret. I was afraid that they would
try to prevent me from leaving.
They later called my mom and confirmed that they would have tried
to stop me from leaving if they knew.
The last bit for this section is that we actually broke up briefly
in April 2021. They were flirting with two of my friends and
as good friends, they came to me and told me she promptly broke
up with me and got with another person which lasted for a few
months before coming back and saying they wanted to try a relationship
again. That that should have been my first red flag. The rest
of the document is relatively minor in comparison to these instances,
but I believe it was important to share to highlight the entirety
of our relationship. For our financial situation, they made about
$250,000 a year, which while I made about $38,000.
Despite this, they would routinely ask me to foot the bill for
our GDQ trips, which was about $1,500 for the hotel room for
the week. Only once or twice did they ever split the bill with
me for the past 5 years. Another important aspect of our relationship
is that I'm severely depressed and struggle with thoughts. I
would often vent on my alt account about these thoughts. She
usually never reached out to me regarding these instances privately
and rarely commented on these posts. I do not know if they did
just did not see them or they were actively avoiding addressing
them. You may ask why I didn't want vent to Shay directly, but
as a part of my depression, I struggled with reaching out to
people one-on-one about these issues, not wanting to feel like
a burden, and the lack of care shown did not help.
Um, I I'm like maybe a slightly more sympathetic to this one
that if she was if he was aware that she's like talking about
keeping herself and he just never ever ever checks in. That's
pretty weird. Right
now, is that like abusive? Is that something you could be canceled
over? No. But it's certainly like concerning that this is your
partners who you're like living with, spending your all your
time with. You just don't check in.
That's not right. Right. During GDQs, we would also rarely see
each other except when we slept. So, this is uh what games done
quick. These are like speedrunning land events.
We would occasionally hang out or have meals together, but it
wasn't common. Something noteworthy is that while we were hanging
out alone, they would often suddenly go, "I'm going to go hang
out with X. See you later." without inviting me. I'd understand
if I didn't know the person, but this was usually with mutual
friend groups who I'd ask an hour later if I can join them. There
were times I'd go to sleep not knowing where they were or who
they were with. As far as our like it sounds to me almost all
of their problems are probably coming from him wanting to go
somebody like wanting interactions, right?
It seems like there's just no compatibility here. One of them
wants one of them wants consistent interactions, the other one
doesn't. It's pretty obvious that all of this stuff is going
to just be he doesn't think this is a long-term thing or he is
Yeah, I don't know.
I do think it's a little weird as well. The financial thing if
you're making like that much more than your partner. While while
I don't expect you to foot the bill for everything or be like
a total s, I would expect you to like
I mean split the bill more than once in the past 5 years or twice.
Uh I guess we'd have to see proof for that. This would be, if
true, this would be a really weird thing to me.
Um, mostly cuz like if you're making that much more money than
your partner, if you insist on splitting everything, you're like
restricting your own life to make sure you split things like
this. Like unless your partner had some hangup about it or some
anxiety, you're you're restricting your own life. You're like
just going to you're just going to build up um like animosity
towards the partner in the relationship, right? If you're never
going to do the things you want cuz they can't afford it, but
you could afford to pay for both of you. Uh, I don't really feel
better, but thank you for saying I sound better. Technommancer,
I appreciate it. What if GDQ something only the partner really
wanted to go to?
Uh, maybe, but this guy's a speedrunner, so I can't see it only
being the partner who wanted to go,
right? That that's literally it's a speedrunning event. He is
a speedrunner. I would imagine he's a part of the people who
want to go to that event.
I guess they met through these communities cuz all of the people
who do this Discord just meet in these communities, right? Okay.
During GDQs, we rarely see each other. He would go and hang out
and she would go to sleep not knowing who they were with. As
far as our living situation went, issues arose almost immediately.
I quickly became the person to do everything around the house.
Laundry, grocery shopping, taking care of the garbage, dishwashing,
and general cleaning. The only thing they did themselves was
vacuuming, which was only once during the entire 2 and a half
months I was there. During the times we ate together, we usually
did not talk. I mean, it depends on is this the
agreed upon split? is like this guy doing consistent work, consistently
streaming, and then was this a part of your agreement to live
there? Does he charge you rent? If you guys split the rent on
this place, if you split the bills, which would be crazy, but
if you did split the bills, then this is like [__]
insane to me. During the times we ate together, we usually did
not talk. They were too busy on the their phone. I chocked it
up to being an extremely busy person, but considering how often
they were interacting with people, the chances are higher that
they were just doing that instead. I should Yeah, I think this
is obviously true, right?
Like I think this is clearly it just seems like this guy is spending
a ton of time doing things with other people instead of interacting
with his partner. I don't know why he decided like this was okay,
but
it's kind of odd.
I should note that they seem to have severe social the severe
social media addiction. They were constantly on their phone or
computer. I remember a few instances of them asking about eating
and then they'd just stay glued to their phone for 2 hours. I'd
remind them a few times about getting food just to get a yeah
1 second and another half hour of scrolling. After we ate, they
generally went to their office, even if they were not streaming
that day until 2 a.m. They would come to bed generally immediately
get on their laptop to continue scrolling before they go to sleep.
It's very rare that we actually interacted with each other throughout
the day. Another minor thing I wanted to note is that they left
their trash laying around. There would be up to 10 cans of soda
sitting on the counter along with boxes of empty soda containers.
I cleaned it up myself since it bothered me. They would also
tend to leave glasses and silverware laying around despite us
having a dishwasher. The glasses.
So, I can already see what this is. Is I'm going to guess that
this is this guy saying, "Well, I pay for everything, so you
should clean." And then
it starts to be a thing where she feels like disrespected based
on how much he's doing like or the lack of him doing stuff. And
then he feels like, "Well, I pay the rent and so you should clean."
You know, it's the Teeone situation,
pretty clearly this person's living with them. He's probably
paying those bills and
he's expecting this girl to clean up.
That that seems like most likely to me. Okay, we keep reading.
They leave glasses out.
The glasses would be covering the counter and sink. When I would
go away and come back after a few days, there was usually silverware
with crusted food sitting in the sink. I had to be the one to
put it in the dishwasher despite never actually using one before.
I originally cleaned them by hand before learning how to use
it. The last thing I wanted to mention is related to financial
decisions. I have a 2011 Sentra and they have a 3-year-old Camaro.
Despite this, they traded in the Camaro and then spent $100,000
on a Corvette. I recently got into an accident, busted the front
of my car. They stated that they wanted to wait on me getting
a new car since they just bought their Corvette. On top of this,
it appears that they were regularly helping our friends out financially,
such as flying them to GDQ, helping with groceries, etc. While
I'm glad they did, it's notable that they usually did not offer
to help me in any way with my finances, especially in the case
of the car, which had obvious damage and was potentially a danger
to drive.
>> Oh, gentle whale 10 gifted. Let's go. >> Huge
W.
Damn.
>> Okay, that is more than just the hour. Thank you very
much, gentle whale. I'll throw up the hour for now. 12.
And we'll figure it out after the fact. I'm just going to leave
that all up there for now. Okay.
Now,
man, this is one of those cases where I I think so, not on this,
not on some of the maybe what would you call it? like ignoring
ignoring maybe not some of the the relationship dynamics, but
on the financial stuff, I do think that the other person would
have a reasonable
I
it could go either way, but if I had to guess, usually when I
hear about that stuff, it's like
this person, the person on the other side, the person who's making
more money, like wants this person to do certain stuff and they're
like not doing it somehow, right? Like, hey, you need to go to
school, you need to do something, blah blah blah blah blah, right?
Usually, usually that is how that goes. Like this person would
not be doing something and so they're like, "Well, I don't really
want to do the car thing right now." But with other people, there's
none of those negative feelings. So, they're like, "Oh yeah,
I have extra money. I'll give you some money." It's still bad.
It's that she's driving her car around like her busted up car
or something when he's got the money to fix it. But it is a little
weird that
I'm guessing there's like another side to this story specifically
with the money, the cars, and and this stuff.
It shows a consistent pattern of behavior that routinely disrespects
and invalidates me. I thought some of this behavior as in uh
I thought of some of this behavior as endearing through roast
tinted glasses. But putting all of this together and hearing
about the experiences of my friends, I can no longer turn a blind
eye to the fact that he did not seem to care about me in the
same way that I did them. Oh, they I we have pronoun stuff. This
person must be non-binary. I I want to note that I do not blame
any of my friends for participating in what was essentially them
cheating on me. They had no idea I didn't know was this is not
fair. This is absolutely not fair.
I'm sorry.
Why even shack up with an girlfriend to financially abuse them
when he could do that to a girlfriend that would have sex with
them? Okay.
God damn it. I started reading your message, BB Poison, as if
it was serious. And now I look like an [__] for reading
it. That's a goofy.
He didn't even get out of it. What the
oldest profession and she got out of work. Okay. Goofy. Goofy
ass.
All right.
So, I do not think the cheating thing is fair given that she
said, "Oh, well, I'm a and I agree have relationships and I didn't
want to hear about any of them."
Now, she maybe she'll add more context that like, hey, if actually
I said if it was a friend, I wanted to know. And then maybe you
could argue this, but if you say you don't want any details of
their encounters with other people and they don't give you any,
you can't be upset. You can't be mad. That's your rules. You
You made the rules.
They're your rules.
The man
anyway. Uh,
dude, my What the [__] is happening? Okay, I need
to stop this.
And I'm not
No, I'm not hallucinating that. Dude, I had like a little shake
going on here. Like the text was shaking. I was like losing it.
Jesus.
So, he she says, "Uh, I don't blame anybody who cheated on me
or something cuz he told them they that I approved of it. I'll
admit because of this and the previous breakup, I had a strong
fear that they would leave me. I loved them dearly and did not
know what I would do if they left me. I live with them after
all. I assumed a lot of it was based on me being insecure rather
than problems they were causing and forced myself to accept these
aspects and behaviors from them. That is why I did not say anything
or stand up for myself, although I really should have. All this
is very complicated for me. As I'm writing this, I'm still not
sure the situation is fully set in for me. Someone I thought
I'd spend the rest of my life with is suddenly revealed to be
doing terrible things to the people I love. Oh, right. So, they're
also grappling with the fact I'm guessing that they didn't have
issues or something and that they learned about some of the other
allegations and so they came forward with their allegations,
right? I'm guessing that's the that's probably the order of operations
here that this person wasn't going to write a document. In fact,
they were still just recently living with this guy. And then
they find out about some of the stuff happening and they go,
"Oh, this guy's bad. This guy's real bad."
I do hope Sheay is able to take a step back from everything and
improve their behaviors and how they view the people around them.
A part of me still loves him or still loves them. However, these
are clear patterns of behavior that are unacceptable with how
they treated people.
Dude, are you guys seeing this? Am I Am I having a stroke or
is the text shaking very slightly? It stopped. It stopped.
It is. Okay. You see it? Jesus Christ. Okay. Like it's actually
my brain is going to explode from the shaking. It's so weird.
What is causing that? It's like something about the zoom. I don't
even know. I'm sitting here trying not to die. It's like something
to do with the the
It's something to do with how my my mouse is working.
Okay. Anyway,
so hope they a part of me still loves them. However, there are
clear patterns of behavior that are unacceptable in how they
treated people. I hope they can get better, but I hope they do
it away from me and my friends for everyone's safety.
Okay, so there's another person. This is
Okay, these images. Can I set my extension not to do images?
I want to God damn it. I want to be able to make sure that this
doesn't um
like invert this the right way, but this is just one of the This
is one of the victims. So, we're looking at the document. It's
got like all the victim's testimony in it. This is one of the
victims here.
Note that timestamps are in GMT because I put this doc together
while on vacation in England. This is 6 hours ahead of my usual
time zone. This was rushed out because of how stressful it was
to try to put this together. All while the public on Twitter/blue
sky/ discord was speculating and harassing other victims in the
interest of chasing the drama instead of respecting our safety
and
I am Aspen/Aspaspen.
I was friends with Shay for a few years starting in early 2022.
We originally started talking in Twitter DMs which for better
or worse which have for better or worse been lost to time because
I deactivated my Twitter account a year or two ago at this point
to contextualize my age throughout the rest of this document.
I was born in late I was born late November 2004. So it was a
few months into being 17 at this point.
Can we get some DJs in here? Um she was basically 18. She was
17 in X months. She was 17 in this many months.
this guy needs the defense squad right now. Stat
wave. Oh my god. Hi.
So, November 2004.
Okay, so 17 at this
17 in 4 months. Oh my god. Hi. Other upside to Discord. I use
emotes way too much and Twitter doesn't allow that. At the time,
I was significantly less experienced with dealing with my anxiety
and struggled with my mental health. And at the time, Sheay was
one of the people that I would talk to about these things. At
this time, they were very willing to converse and support me,
talking me through a m a breakdown on multiple different occasions.
At times, I would give compliments, calling them cute primarily,
and things in that vein. They reciprocated these thoughts in
a way that was, in hindsight, not appropriate given my age, 17,
and theirs, 22 or 23.
Um, that is not a crazy age gap, is it? I mean, this is like
on the edge. It's
I don't This is like a way different thing, right? This is um
Man, it's like It's right on the edge. He's like what? College
senior.
We get like a college freshman,
high school senior. High school senior.
17 and 23 is a little crazy. I mean, it's it's like kind of weird.
Yeah.
Adults hanging around high schoolers is weird.
Um, sure. I think it's weird. It's definitely weird.
It's not quite the same as some other
I don't I would never advise this guy to do this, right? There's
like this is like in the final area where this is kind of can
be like uh maybe maybe I sort of understand.
That's just me personally. Well,
uh I would think he's weird if I knew him, but this isn't a wood
chipper vibe. Well, it also depends on like what he's doing,
what ages, what he knew for age here. I'm trying to think of
like there'd be a couple things that go into this. And also,
if there's like a pattern of him targeting women at this age,
which they've implied, that would also be bad, right? If he was
consistently like targeting or having sex interactions with high
schoolers,
it would also be very weird.
The compliments are are
inappropriate. Okay, let's keep watching. Fun fact, you're cute.
Takes one to no one. Shut. No, I don't. Okay,
so some flirting. No, I don't think I will. You [__]
Hope you're having a good night. Also, I'm very complimenting
person, so prepare yourself.
come on, man. Come on.
It's the Asmin Gold tweet over and over again. It's like the
Asminold tweet.
This was literally the response Asmin Gold got from his tweet.
Asiggo is participating in Discord culture right
These are responses to him, by the way. Okay. All right.
All right. It was It was just a weird reply. Okay. It was just
odd.
Moving on.
The real kicker of this conversation is when I was talking about
worrying about not passing while wearing a dress, and they took
what was meant to be a comment about how I was insecure about
my shoulders to be about my gawk entirely
How did Chudlo Logic read these?
This is like a This guy's like a young Chudlo Logic. Absolutely.
It's like just Chaser. It's a Chaser documentary right here.
There's no way.
Hold on.
I'm so dude. I didn't realize
this is crazy. What is Hold on.
There's no way this guy built like an entire community of like
his fetish, right? There's no way. It's not possible. Oh yeah,
I like skirts. Dresses kind of scare me. I unfortunately can't
really pass in a dress. I mean, I think you pass just fine enough
without anything special. Unfortunately, dresses kind of exposed
the more giveaway traits. Wait, people can't appreciate some
gawk.
That wasn't what I meant. But that too, I guess. What else was
that supposed to be referring to? Wait, he's actually real. Hold
on. I would assume that's the reason women like trans people
wouldn't wear dresses. The interaction is very
Uh, I was thinking about my shoulders.
Wait, but he he just said the most obvious thing. Okay. He said
the second most obvious thing. First thing, jawline. Second thing.
Okay. I I don't think that's a crazy jump. Maybe that's like
a weird thing when you're talking to a minor. I I feel like at
the end of this I'm going to go back and apologize to Marjgery
Taylor Green. MTG might have been right. Okay.
No more transing the kids. It's this is
We need a total and complete shutdown of
hormones coming over the border, okay, until we can figure out
what the is going on. Later in the same conversation, they commented
on my NFTts, which as far as myself or anyone else can figure
out is nice and that I look cute uh and that my then partner
is V VV lucky to the certain extent you could argue that is reassurance,
but the comments about my P and breast are unsavory at best.
Oh god, he gets worse. Okay, this one was defensible, but what
is this? This in England, so it's 6 hours ahead. So, this should
be
9:00 a.m. 9:30 p.m.
on like the East
Yeah. Yeah. >> Shay just tipped five buff. Yo, listen up.
It's Shay. Stop misgendering me. >> It's they them also
in black.
>> Okay. Thank you. It's they them, homie. All right. Thank
you, Jay. I mean, I'm looking at the first photo you sent me,
and nothing about that screams, "These shoulders do not look
like a woman's, and that has bare shoulders. Not sure how long
you've been on HRT, but I mean, IMO, I think you really already
passed really well." I don't know if how anybody would look at
that picture and think otherwise. Lol. You even got some NFTts
in there. What? Think I what? Think I couldn't handle it? I mean,
you do look really cute in this. Like I said, your partner is
V Lucky.
Uh, yeah. These are weird. I don't know. I'm more just still
confounded by the chaser thing.
Insert lykans. You pass like a comment. Yeah, but that's too
that's to an adult. That's just being cringe.
That's not being like borderline weird with minors. This I'm
just going to say another thing that's obviously true that we
all know is true. Okay.
Chasers are very fluid with um with age restrictions. Okay.
Like there is
it's weird. It's really [__] weird.
I think it has something to do with the fact that people who
start HRT late like don't pass as well. And so there's something
to do with like chasers of male to female trans people are looking
for somebody who's more feminine and like started hormones earlier
and there's always like a youth thing going on there, right?
It's very but I think it's like undeniable that that is the case
is a very weird anybody who's a chaser you
cut like a cut like any open chaser and a bleeds unironically.
Okay.
talk wants to trans the kids. Dude, do you remember was it was
it Richard Hania and Briana Woo who were tweeting about the Hunter
Schaefer person were like this is why you need to trans the kids
so that they can like remain feminine as
It was like the most absurd tweet. The most like conservative
hate fuel propaganda tweet I've ever seen in my entire life.
Right.
It was like you need to trans the kids cuz you could only have
women this beautiful if they don't go through through puberty.
Male puberty. It's like
So for your desires, we should like make kids infertile. That's
that's what you want. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Just writing you on a
list. Oh, the what? It's a Well, the title of the list is who
goes on the wall first, but we're talking about like Trump when
he builds the wall. You can go up for a visit. Okay. Who faces
the wall first? Well, faces. I mean, you can stand on top of
the wall. But listen, you're you're at the top of the list for
the wall. Okay. Nothing direct here, but a couple instances of
them being a bit too concerned about being cancelled in a way
that seems to be foreshadowing something. You forgot the gay.
If I made that joke, if is my platform big enough to get cancelled
for career baiting or whatever, or do I have to get a million
subscribers first? Oh, no. Don't compliment me. Anything but
that. I feed off of compliments lately. Honestly, it makes me
feel very confident in myself. But it's okay. I will power use
my power
What? This is disconnected from context. I don't know what the
context is. Additionally, very clear on that they were willing
to objectify very clear early on that they were willing to objectify
their fans and friends so far as that to say they revel in their
simps. Why would I deny it? I'm hot. So true. Why do you think
I have so many simps? Uh, charisma. Sure. Not that I mind having
simps, of course. I mean, I sort of revel in it at this point.
Okay. No, these aren't even weird messages. These aren't weird
messages at all. On June 26th, 2022, during S uh SGDQ, which
we were both attending, they sent a suggestive image of them
shirtless to the best of my ability to discern the context. This
was while we were sitting on a bed next to each other in the
same room, IRL.
But regardless of context, weird thing to send to a 17-year-old.
Okay. I I'm just curious. They have a very flirty dynamic. They
have a very like like there's undercurrens of their
I I don't know. I guess this this is like grooming. It's it's
it's probably pretty rough. I really doubt that this guy had
no idea what her age was.
Yeah. Send a picture together on a bed. I mean, this guy is trying
to obviously
he wants to [__] That's what he wants. Oh, this will
be the big tell, though. How heavily does he ramp up sec? It
seems like he was willing to when you were 17 though. Image not
attached for privacy reasons. But for your sake, but for your
sake reading this, there was no context to this being sent. It
was in the middle of a series of messages that we were just spamming
funny Discord stickers at each other. As I approached 18 years
old, they started complimenting me and calling me cute more and
more. The worst of this was on Snapchat, which I unfortunately
can't supply more than this screenshot I had in my camera roll
because I don't have Snapchat anymore. And these are all as I
was approaching 18 years old at the end of November.
Okay, this guy's like the inverse the the reverse legal mindset.
Okay, legal mindset. When somebody turns 18, they stop talking
to him. This guy's like, "Oh, you're getting you're about to
become legal. We're going to ramp it up." Like the opposite.
Cute. Thank you. Good morning, cutie. You look great. You look
so good. OML.
Wait, is this just one-sided him calling you cute repeatedly?
The After I turned 18, the demeanor towards me immediately changed
to be significantly more overtly
Hope you're doing well. I am. I'm glad you deserve it. Cutie
also adorable. I want a head pat. Wait. Okay. Not that this is
like
absolving him. But is she not the person engaging in the flirting
first? Is like she's 18 at this point now. She was You could
You would make the argument that she was groomed. Sure.
But like they're engaging in it here. He's not even ah he's probably
just as guilty.
Plausible deniability for this
Additionally, within the same conversation, they accepted my
advancement to talking about kissing platonically and but more
importantly, this was the first time we talked about Stars Star
Smiley, their then partner boundaries about flirting and being
with other people. They were for several years in a monogous
relationship in which they stated their star that Star was said
she was okay with them to engage in these relations with other
people. But she later clarified they never communicated properly
about this.
Okay, so Star is the first one we read, like the very first introduction
that was from Star Smiley.
Next time I see you, I want to give you a huge hug. That would
be nice. Reminder, these allegations as well as some others led
to them doing like this big cancellation document where they
collected everybody's testimony and like basically said all the
bad things this guy did, right? So, I'm expecting there to be
like some crazy [__] here. Not.
This is getting
I don't know. Maybe maybe I just don't recognize the signs here
of how aggressive this flirting is. Dude, what do Usually when
you see gay people flirting, okay? People who engage in these
communities, chasers, gay people. When they're flirting, they're
like overtly all the time. It's gross to read. Like, it's actually
gross to read. This is like super tame in a way that feels, but
I honestly in a way that feel like this feels like I'm engaging
like they're flirting with like a child. Like they're pretending
to be a child. This person's a child. There is something
about this communication.
I can't be the only person who picks that up, right? When they're
constantly talking like their kids and they're like too embarrassed
to say their feelings and
it's just like incredibly
coded. Okay, next time I see you, I want to give you a huge hug.
That would be nice. And I don't know what you're comfy with,
but I've me you've mentioned platonic kissing. I think I did
mention that. Hi. I love platonic kissing. Good to know. This
is not a thing. Platonic like kissing. At least with If you're
making out, that's not a thing. Platonic kissing is not a thing.
That's some Britney Simon [__] Oh, I just shower
with my friends and it's not Shut up. That's wrong. You're wrong.
You're wrong. You're wrong. You're wrong.
Okay, to be fair, I'm down for a lot more platonically than most
people are. Take that as you will. Platonically shove your fist
up my ass. Okay. Platonically. Platonically,
just not in a way. Okay. I'm only recently exploring platonic
affection. So, I think I'll just get just so I think I'll just
stick to getting head paths. Oh,
okay. That's so valid. That's so so valid. I also want to make
sure I'm respecting both you and Star's boundaries. I take it
she's okay with you doing these things. Yep. Good. That feels
like it should have been given. A given, but you'd be surprised
how many people don't take that into consideration. Hello. Yeah,
I know. I've asked her about it, of course. Good. Good. It honestly
astounds me how often people just like easily violate things
that should be respected at the most basic level in relationships.
Like respecting your partner's boundaries is
Screenshot dated November 18th, 2025. I mentioned a bit in the
Discord, but while I gave general permission to do stuff with
others, they never told me that who they were doing it with or
when. I'm g I guessed you two had something going on based on
bits and pieces. There are numerous flirtatious conversations
like above from shortly after I turned 18 that I will skip over
for brevity. Wait,
so the star smiley person when they gave their stuff here, let
me go back to the star smiley page.
That's this one. They said, um, so there's an important part
of this relationship that you need to understand going to all
of this. I identify as a and I'm not interested in doing anything
with anyone. Sheay was aware of this and generally respected
that throughout the relationship. I understood that they needed
a outlet and agreed that they could have contact with others.
I did not request that they tell me who it was or who it was
with or when it happened, but I will go into how it was handled
poorly.
you didn't ask for any details. You didn't ask for transparency
on any of it. And they didn't do it. As I mentioned previously,
I agreed they could have contact with others and did not specify
that they had to tell me when it happened or who it was with.
I did not expect them to be having this behavior with nearly
20 people nearly constantly throughout the entire relationship.
So, her problem isn't even with having it. She didn't want to
be told. She's just like, "Oh, I didn't realize you were trying
to [__] a bunch of people." That's all. That's the
only
It's weird that they're saying, "Oh, this wouldn't be
He's not lying here. He's not lying at all."
Okay, we continue. I'll note here that starting the starting
here late 2023 until around October of 2025. Wait,
was this person trans, too? Wait,
hold on. That's a different statement.
Oh, hold on. That's I see. No, it's on a different page. Is his
Is his partner trans as well?
Or is it this person?
I need I need a
chromosome check on his current partner, the star person. All
right. I need chromosome checks right now.
Someone got to let me know. X Y
X. It's fine. We'll figure it out as we
Later in the conversation, I established that I was feeling repulsed
and that's why I was deflecting their advances and again, wait,
hold on. Did I go past a page? Yes, I did. I'll note here that
starting in late 2023 until around October 2025, they only reached
out or engaged in conversations with me when they were horny.
Every other conversation is dry best or in some cases just didn't
even get a reply. This isn't a pattern and that I noticed until
the events at SGDQ 2025 that I'll cover later, but it's worth
noting.
On one occasion, while we were talking about or we were while
we were talking, they told me to come lay on their lap. And given
my exhaustion at the time, I said I would probably fall asleep.
They made a comment about hoping I don't do anything silly while
I slept. Okay. I can't think of any other way to read that than
as a threat. What? What? Come here and lay on my lap for a while,
please. I'm gonna fall asleep on you. Probably just a heads up.
That's okay. Hope you don't do anything silly while you're asleep.
I don't know what this is. I don't read it as a threat. What
do you mean a threat? I don't I don't understand.
I don't I literally don't understand that comment.
I can't read it as anything but a threat. What's the threat?
That he's going to rape you? He's trying to be He's trying to
I don't know why he said or maybe don't fall asleep is like the
normal reply there. I don't I don't know why she's not 17 at
this point. She's 18
at this point in 2023.
Later in the same conversation, I established that I was feeling
and that's why I was deflecting their advances and again expressed
worry for Stars boundaries to which they assured me reassured
me that it was okay. That's gay. Hi, sorry I'm like vaguely ace
leaning at the moment and don't know where your boundaries are
so I'm being silly instead of engaging. H that's fine.
Is this right after? Oh, this is Hold on. So this is right after
she identifies that as she says, "Hey, I don't really want to
do that." Uh, that's fine. You're a close friend, so I'd be okay
with that stuff from you. But yeah, I mean, if you're ace leaning,
then whatever. You're comfy with friend. I appreciate you being
considerate. I just don't really know what that stuff you're
comfy with.
What that stuff you're comfy with. Be okay with that stuff from
you,
you're comfy with, and where your boundaries are, especially
with Star. I'm not trying to get in the way of a happy relationship.
Oh, haha. She's okay with me being friends. Don't worry.
Okay. I was very clear how important communication about things
like this was for me.
All right.
Why are the emotes in black base? Because I would rather have
the background be black than this be the correct color. This
is like inverted colors on all of the screenshots.
So they continue on right after this. We'd never talked about
anything past like cuddling and stuff. This communication is
very important. So true. So so so true.
Okay. What I expressed I I still don't see anything. So, other
than the age discrepancy and the concerning like possibility
of grooming here,
I don't know
what the other allegations are. All of these messages are being
painted as sinister is just people flirting. There is literally
nothing going on here at all.
when expressed discomfort that they were posting suggestive/nude
images untagged on their private Twitter account. They responded
about they responded worried about the reach of their posts again
on a private Twitter account and suggest rather suggested that
they remove me from the circle. I was clear that I use my private
Twitter account to follow my friends accounts and seeing images
was by far the outlier and they still pushed that I should just
be removed or that I should make a separate account for that
to which I did despite not really wanting to do that given my
age.
Okay, so you tried to police what they post on their private
Twitter account. They told you to [__] off and then
you are mad about it. Okay,
little bro got to censor your Twitter post. I'm in class. Why
are you checking your private Twitter in class? Censoring post
engagement. I don't like doing it. Fair enough. I was going to
reply one of my posts earlier. I feel like I've said this before.
It's kind of annoying, not going to lie. That's fair. Like if
you don't want to follow that, I can remove you from the circle,
but like it's something you willingly asked for on that account.
I feel like it's strange to complain about checking something
you know is suggestive as hell in a public space. Yeah. If he
just post on his account unfollow the account.
Maybe that's that is a red flag though if you if you're like
well I want to be able to interact with you in your private Twitter
that you also post your thoughts on but why do you have to post
your thoughts and it's like oh maybe this guy is like he's got
some weird boundaries got some weird dynamics you know his his
engagement with topics and
uh what would you say not topics just his engagement with is
like sort of taking over a lot of his life right like that's
probably a red flag if you don't like that you I can't think
of a bigger red flag than hey I'm just here with my homie Shmp.
Yeah, it's a massive red flag, bro.
What? What? Well, he's not doing it for content creation. It's
a private Twitter. But he he could just say, "Well, no, just
like go don't follow the Twitter account." Pretty easy.
I mean, it's also just the account that I use to see my friends
posts. The those posts are like by far the outlier. And sometimes
I just want to see my friends post without getting nudes jump
scared. I don't know. Okay, then. Do you want to follow on that
account or not?
My account post. My account post nudes. You don't like that,
don't follow the account. Real simple. I've I've broken it down
for you. It's super simple. Okay. Either follow or you don't.
Not confusing, not hard, not difficult.
Make the decision. Why does he want engagement on his private
Twitter? I actually don't know. Wants people to see his
Yeah, I don't know. I mean, that account also just has regular
posts, does it not? And like, I do want to see those posts. I
would just rather choose before seeing these images. I don't
know. I need the circle silly. There's no regular posts in there.
All the regular posts are just regular posts. I mean, yeah, it's
just the problem of like I want to see the posts, but it's also
like do you have a different account you want to use then? I
don't have another account. Lol. I have my main and my private
and another account that I never open. Don't you literally follow
accounts on your priv? No. Lauo, I swear I remember you showing
me your timeline was full of that stuff. Maybe I'm misremembering.
Sometimes my main gets bad because I follow a lot of artists
and it's like, you know, sometimes artists get silly. Either
way, engagement, so I'm not putting a spoiler tag on it. That's
fair. I don't really see how that would affect engagement. I
mean, it's the algorithm definitely affects engagement, but if
it's a private Twitter, that doesn't really make sense.
Aren't there spoilers for nudes on Twitter? There are, and they
get applied automatically now. Maybe they're not getting applied
automatically back here anyway because I want to see Well, they
get applied automatically eventually. So, I want to see I want
people to see them. I mean it's the whole reason it's there lau
actually completely untrue lol like the people you who follow
you are going to see it regardless.
so he's like well of the people who follow my private sometimes
they don't see my if I post my and
it get it's censored so like I need more people who are my friends
to see my obviously I cannot continue to censor it.
Makes sense. Totally degenerate. Totally a red flag. Hey, this
person does not have healthy engagement with with sex in any
way. Hey, total red flag here, bro. Total red flag.
Just so you know,
they also proceeded to say, "I was being condescending for this
concern, citing their experience with content creation as if
that excuses it." Okay, if this is how this conversation is going
to be, I really don't want to have it. I'm already kind of annoyed
and this is just making it worse. Good luck on the rest of your
classes. Not like I need to worry about it anyway. Circle is
dead in like a week anyway. Sorry. Wanted to understand your
perspective. It's just annoyingly condescending. Like, I do content
creation and social media stuff for a living. I know what I'm
talking about. Is that how Kenny got the mod job?
No. Kenny was just around a lot. And he's trustworthy. I trust
Kenny with
let's see. There seems to be some confusion here. What's this
circle?
Like, is he talking about a Twitter com he made or it seems like
they're referring to different things. They keep saying circle,
Circle is dead in like a week anyway.
I don't know. Sorry. Wanted to understand your perspective. It's
just annoyingly condescending. Blah blah blah blah blah. In this
conversation, they were making more advances than than I was
comfortable with. And I tried diverting the conversation and
diffusing. This is a different day. It's the next year and diffusing
it, but they kept pushing their fantasies on me in in the moment.
A decent portion of our conversations during this time, 2023
to 2025, were somewhat similar to this, with me eventually giving
into their pressure. I will not continue posting more screenshots
of conversations like this, but in but it is a couple thousand
messages over dozens of conversations.
Fair. I wasn't sure if she was coming up. Cute. If we if we can,
I want to cuddle for a while at some point. Comfy bed 100%.
Order right now. Wish someone was giving me head to be honest.
Cuddles after
Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, use your words. I want to cuddle. Anything else?
Mainly cuddle. That implies something else,
Okay. Sometimes
you listen, I
there's probably a pattern here that could get unhealthy. I don't
want to totally undermine all of this. Right now, it's like nothing.
Okay. Currently, nothing. If there was a pattern of him, you
know, constantly messaging viewers and then refusing to engage
unless they're willing to engage. That could be like concerning,
right? He's pushy. I mean, he's been pushy like one time with
this basically. I feel like I've seen the one one time where
he feels like he's being pushy.
Otherwise, he's mostly ma matching energy.
I think if he's like consistently doing this, then maybe that
gets bad at some point. I've not seen anything horrible like
this. If this is a one-off of him being pushy like this, you
could probably explain this. It's 11:30. Maybe he's drunk or
something,
but we'll we'll keep watching. at SGDQ2024.
They're interested in hanging out with me with many DMs like
the ones below wanting to hang out. We cuddled while there were
a number of people in the room, including but not limited to
Star being in the same bed in the bed at the same time. Given
the context of what happened in this situ in this same situation
when I was alone with Shay the next year, I wholeheartedly believe
their presence saved me from being assaulted here.
Okay. Hey gamer, when do you get here? I'm here. Sorry, I forgot
to mention. Got dragged to the mall right away. No worries, I'm
out at the moment. Are you out still? All my friends are watching
a run right now and I can't. Uh, I'm in the broadcast room. Wanted
to see the PB run. Heads up. I'm in the hotel for the foreseeable
future. Did you want to hang out? Yeah. When are you available?
I'm in the middle of a bunch of people who hate planning. If
you just want to hang out, I'm in my room. Here's the room number.
We did the same later that day. And I similarly suspect that
the constant presence of other people in the room was the only
thing saving me.
Okay.
Wait, does she is she saying she got assaulted in 2025 or is
she talking about the star person being assaulted?
yeah, I don't know. We'll keep watching. Keep reading. You busy?
No, not at all. Is that an invitation? Yep. I'll head
Foreshadowing a similar way they treated me at the next GDQ.
They did not talk to me or respond to any of my DMs that were
not related to me coming and hanging out with them in person.
In this conversation, I was I very explicitly told them I wasn't
horny, and they still tried to make an advancement. You're so
gay. Sorry, I'm just kind of not in a horny mood right now. Damn,
I can fix that. What?
Bonk.
Okay, so
there is like a there is a thing here. Okay, he's making an advancement.
She says sorry. He tries one more press. One more quick press.
He gets told no. I think after like one or two, you get like
one or two,
maybe three if you're horny. Okay. Sorry, not if you're horny,
if you're drunk or if you're inebriated in some way. But then
you got to off at some point. Like you do got to off at some
point if he's like consistently pressuring. We'll see. This bonk
should be like that ends it right there. It seems to have ended
it. There's no more
I think like this is like annoying, but this is not I'm sorry.
It doesn't need to be cancelceled. This is not disgusting behavior,
right?
This is not disgusting. I'm sorry. It's like at most he's being
like a weirdo.
No one to take a hint. I mean, he is basically he's Listen,
I'm making allowances for like when this guy's drunk. Is it the
best conduct? No. But maybe this guy gets like a little wasted
and he, you know, over pushes a little bit on text.
On text. I'm not excusing him like somebody. I'm not excusing
him assaulting somebody. But maybe he like gets curved a little
bit and he's like, "Are you sure?" And they're like, "Yeah."
Uh, and then he flipped it off. I'm not going to pillar this
guy for that. Doesn't seem to make any sense. For the main event,
SGDQ 2025. They seem to be excited to me uh to see me in anticipation,
and I was excited to see them. They continued to try to get me
to come hang out, all while I was unaware it would be oneonone.
I assumed their friends or at least Star would be in the room.
What I did not know at the time was that they did this as this
purely with the intent of having sex with me.
GDQ today. Excited to see you. I'm here. Let me know sometime
if you're free to say hi. I'm in the lobby for now. I just woke
up. I'm in 1123.
Yeah. Face well from Texas. Thank you very much for the sub.
Four months. Oh, usurp. Also, thank you for the 21 months. Appreciate
it, guys.
That's getting pretty close to pushing us over the number.
We're two $2 away for another hour on the stream. Let me see
here. Is that right? So, 75. It should be 80. Yeah, we're like
$2 away. I'll just add the hour right now.
We'll add the hour and then I'll uh refresh the meters here.
Hold on a second. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. There we
go.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Wait, why didn't this reset?
There we go. All right, we're good.
So, this is now maybe going to be the worst example. This is
him in in July.
I would say it's a little concerning that apparently all of this
stuff felt like him pressuring and being overtly most of the
time. There aren't a lot of screenshots in between. Did they
just not talk until they're going to meet up at some game thing
and then I don't know. Yeah, Canadian caller. This is basically
what it is. It's like if this guy is persistently doing this
in many conversations and like farming his community for partners
because they look up to him and like that is that is a different
animal but you have to show it with consistent like stuff over
time. We'll see. I think this is only what, two out of five.
We've got like a couple more instances in here that we're going
to look at. There's more behavior. There's more of this stuff.
We'll see how this goes. Okay, continuing.
Okay, so she's here. She's excited to see him. I'm here. Let
me know if you're free sometime to say hi. I'm in the lobby for
now. I just woke up. I'm in 1123.
Morning, cutie. I think I'm leaving for soon for breakfast, but
I'll catch you in a bit. Ah, if you're free right now, actually,
I could head up. I just helped Cherry bring stuff up to his room
or down actually. Never mind. I lied. I got to go right now.
I'll catch you later. Okay, I'm back now. Come up. Okay, I need
to steal a card from
When I went up to the room under the pretense of hanging out,
they assaulted me. They made advancements and pushed me to do
things I was not comfortable with, but I did not feel safe saying
no given the context, the power they had over me, and the fact
that I was alone with them at the time. I was vulnerable given
unrelated things in my personal life. and it led me to not realize
that I that what had happened until I looked back at it a few
days later. For the rest of the event, they barely responded
to me. I sent around a dozen messages and they gave me one single
ny face and lol, ignoring almost everything I said to them, all
while acting like nothing happened when we were around each other
in person.
Okay. Okay. Um, so you want contemporaneous messages. You want
him them like
I guess what would you say getting upset with them or something
at the time? You want contemporaneous messages, some sort of
confrontation at the time, them documenting it, right? Saying
at this time I feel like I was
That would be what you'd expect. Although I guess it's not that
far in the past. And then I guess we'll see what what there is
for him ignoring. The next time they messaged me was to bring
up what happened in person again. And while I tried deflecting,
they were insistent on it. The other day I was thinking about
what we did at GDQ. That was nice.
HR, how are you?
Hope you got your flight figured out. Also, I never got this
ping. I did get it figured out. Haha. Eventually, I'm doing all
right. Finished college and chilling a bit before I go to England.
Smiley face. Oh, the other day I was thinking about what we did.
I hope this was fun for you, by the way. Haha. Also, congrats
on finishing college. That's huge. Thanks. Big weight off. Uhoh.
I mean,
okay.
Oh, man. There's a lot of different things going on here.
I He's checking in. How far later is this? This is like a month
later,
So, he says he didn't get the ping. That could explain one of
them. And he is saying,
"Oh, like we had like some kind of interaction."
And she actually says it here. Hold on. He's like, "Are you not
responding to this for a reason or so?" I was incredibly uncomfortable
around them at the time and left it at saying I wasn't interested
and that I was feeling repulsed. I was in particularly deep propulsion
about that, but but that was caused by what happened at GDQ.
So, this person clearly has like some feelings of being
that they deal with. I don't know how they've recommended this
be dealt with. I think like I could see him interacting with
this in a way where he doesn't want to make them feel bad about
I'm not totally sure. It does. There's not a lot of details in
the interaction.
Pulseed. I'm guessing this is she said she's feeling repulsed
and sort of a before like the idea of makes her uncomfortable,
makes her feel disgusted.
are you not responding to this for a reason or Yeah, I'm just
not interested. Sorry. What do you mean by that? Just like in
general or right now? Bit of both. Really not interested right
now? I'm sorry. I've been very repulsed recently. So, again,
he might not be aware. So, right now I'm going to I'm unfortunately
going to kind of give him like he might not be that aware of
something done wrong. He might not be that aware of like boundaries
with regards to these people are both
it's there's a lot of things that could be going on here. We
need to establish some kind of pattern like a pattern of behavior
where he is consistently pulling this kind of thing and then
pulling like an ignorance card. At this point, it feels like
neither of these people communicate well.
And unfortunately, like some of this stuff, she is playing it
in the exact way that I would expect him
or them, sorry, would expect the Shay person to think, oh, like
they're excusing
problems that Sheay has done, bad things that Sheay has done
that they're excusing them as as Aspen's personal neurosis or
Aspen's personal problems. She's she seems to be doing the thing
where I the read I get from the messages is, "No, I have a thing
going on. It's not you. I have a thing going on.
Right. That's what it sounds like to me. Later in that conversation,
they tried prompting me again about AGDQ. You going to be at
AGDQ? I was I really like cuddling with you. It was so nice.
Nope. Deaf can't afford it. No.
Now they talked about platonic cuddling before.
I could see how if they think something weird happened, maybe
this is seen as I don't know. It seems like he could be beating
around the bush like he's trying to go to cuddling because it's
a safe middle ground to get them in a bed to like escalate to
sex again. Seems like this person has an issue with escalations,
right? For a lot of a lot of people, you can have a totally normal
interaction. You can have an interaction where you're like meeting
up with somebody and it starts to turn and you can progress to
that and it's okay. For this person, it seems like they see progression.
They see that sort of escalation as something really bad, as
something that they have a hard time saying no to and that they
feel like victimized when they when they don't say no and stuff
happens and they feel like they're a bystander, right?
So, I don't know if they knew that if they communicated that
to this person that that's the best that's like the most charity
I can give them cuz they're clearly not communicating even that
they had a problem yet. Around this time, we started having actual
conversations occasionally, which I can only suspect was because
around this time we were they were uh around this time people
were starting to come up privately with stories um about Sheay
that they became aware of.
Okay, so in September he started like actually talking back to
her. Weird
weird that like that's a noted thing. Eventually I reached out
about my experience with them after I had already shared part
of my story with relevant people. I hoped at that time this was
them genuinely making an effort to make good on their mistakes
and be better a better friend, but I now know that it was simply
them trying to cover their tracks and save face. Their apology
seemed genuine and uh and I bit hey, sorry I've been awkward
and not
I've been struggling a lot with things and haven't known how
to handle it. To put it bluntly, reflecting ever since GDQ, I
felt incredibly hurt and used by you over the past couple of
years. I began feeling this way at GDQ, but upon reading back
through our DMs, it was very clear you only ever talked to me
in more than a couple of very dry messages when you wanted to
use me for reflecting on GDQ this year and last made it clearer.
You talked to me when you wanted to cuddle or have but ghosted
me the rest of the time. It made me feel terrible my about myself
and about the fact that I've considered you a friend for years
just for interactions to boil down to this trend of you only
caring about messaging me when you're horny. I don't think it
would be accurate to call our relationship over the past couple
of years a friendship. And if our friendship is something you
care about, you're going to have to learn to be a good friend.
Hey, thank you for being honest about this. I want to apologize
and also validate that you're feeling what you're feeling because
I was starting to feel the same way and it made me feel incredibly
icky. The truth of the matter is that I enjoy talking to you
and enjoy hanging out with you. I never intended to ghost you
or do anything of the sort. I really just I just really really
struggle to keep up with the amount of social things happening
at an event like that. I do care about our friendship and I promise
that I do. I want to prove that I do and I just want to I want
to just talk about more stuff and hang out more in general.
But I'm sorry for how I made you feel. I've been feeling that
way for from several I've been feeling that way from several
others as well too. Feeling used and I think that can be dangerous.
>> Yo, that's it. You just referred to me as he listen
up little and f to have your tushi in my fist. >> Jesus.
If you do that one more time,
>> I'm probably going to keep misgendering people. Sorry,
but I'm sorry for how I made you feel. Thank you for the five.
I appreciate it. I've been feeling that way from several others,
too. Feeling used. And I think that can be dangerous can be a
dangerous outcome of having interactions in a friendship like
that. The bottom line is I care about you and I want to hang
out more. Promise that I will do better. And again, thank you
for being honest with me.
Uh, I am really sorry for this. I promise it has everything to
do with me just having a low social battery in general. This
is the not messaging her at the GDQ thing. It's nothing against
you personally
and nothing about how I view you. I was just completely shut
down. I I just completely shut down and forget to respond to
things when my social battery is low and then I'll just completely
forget to respond in general because of that. I've been trying
more recently to reach out and just talk about whatever. I feel
like I don't do that enough. I hope that makes sense. Again,
I'm sorry and thank you for telling me. I just I need to know
that I I need you to know that I do care and that I care about
you and I want to make this right. Sometimes it's difficult for
me to discern what I feel people want from me. I only entertain
those interactions because I thought you were enjoying them and
I guess that transformed into me thinking you valued me for that.
And I guess that's just low self-esteem on my end and image issues
I have with myself. But you're a really funny and endearing person.
I just enjoy being around you. I'm sorry I made you feel like
that when it wasn't the case. Can we try again? I want to know
how your UK trip has been going. You're still there, right? Honestly,
I read this as genuine right now. Like, I'm reading the apologies
as pretty genuine. Like, he seems to be reflecting. He's not
He's just He's like validating.
Um
I don't feel like this guy's
I'm not picking it up. Maybe in the other messages we'll see
him being like a total I don't know, totally like freak, total
predator. It seems like he's putting all of this in text. He's
just saying like, "Oh, I feel bad about this." Now, did she say
she felt used for, but she never says that it's like an she never
makes an allegation that she was assaulted? I think that's kind
of important that there's no actual assault allegation back here.
Even doesn't mean it didn't happen, but you'd want to see like
more evidence, you know,
ideally.
Okay. In the month or so following, there were a few conversations
we had that felt that felt real for the first time in years.
Even them reaching out after I posted on my private Twitter during
a breakdown. Also, I saw your other tweet. I hope you're feeling
better. Please don't do anything bad to yourself. But in the
past few days, while learning about other stories and the recency
with which they were continue to abuse and take advantage of
people, it was clear that this was never anything more than an
attempt to save face.
Okay. So again, it's
again, it's like, oh, I didn't see this as a problem. I didn't
think there were a bunch of problems here. But now, after hearing
how they're abusive to other people, I understand
like I I understand there's a pattern. I'll be honest,
other than I think there's assault allegation,
I don't think there's anything abusive here. Oh, there's also
the grooming. Sorry, there's the grooming aspect as well, which
is like it's
[__]
It's definitely bad. Trying to see. It does seem like he eventually
more aggressively talks about like once she's past 17, once she
turns 18.
That does seem to be the case. Oh, she's 18 here,
He doesn't even say. He literally leans out of the kissing thing
here right after she's turned 18. I don't know. It's hard to
read, man. We need more. We need more information. Okay, final
bit here.
Uh Shay, if you're reading this, and I sure hope you are, you
repeatedly pushed me to my limits, and you broke me down into
nothing while I trusted you and forgave you over and over, time
and time again. You took my endless kindness and used it to take
advantage of me and my friends. You and your actions are deplorable,
and I hope you never show your face around here again because
you will never be welcome back.
Um, okay. I guess we need to see the other examples of taking
advantage of people. I'd say this one's another like pass. It's
relying on a lot of other stuff that's going on or building a
pattern. So, oh
wait, they don't have this tabbed out very well at all. Table
of contents.
What actually happened between an Wait, this is not a table of
contents. This is a list of allegations. What the Oh, the subtabs
for Bro, this allegation got subtabs. What the? This is where
things get silly. What do you mean they get silly? They're already
silly. It's silly already. What do you mean it gets silly? How
is this not already silly? Okay, hold on.
Table of contents. What actually happened between anonymous one
and Shay? Opening plus disclaimers. How has this affected me?
The physical and emotional consequences of the situation for
me. Okay. Okay. So, where did this start? Introduction to how
Oh, this is the just Oh, you're just saying what the the sections
are.
Written statements. Screen caps. Control F.
Okay. I Okay, written statement.
I Okay, I can already, Dude, the way this is organized, literally,
just the organization of the document and how this is laid out
already makes me concerned that this is totally stupid. Totally
broken. All right.
What are we doing here? What are we doing here?
Okay, I've not I've seen you not properly explain the situation
to people when you tell them. I know the halftruth you've told.
I want you to drop your ego and be honest. I want you to tell
people you've told in full transparency what you did. You made
a joke targeted towards me over a tweet unrelated to you, which
I only sent because I felt like I had to prove I wasn't a bottom
after you teased me that I was one about me giving you a hickey.
What? That is the truth, dude.
Okay.
Okay. That is the truth. It was not God. I wish that you that
for me it was when am I getting this. You have my permission
to tell them. I know you named dropped me anyway. So go ahead.
It's embarrassing for me, but they deserve to know the truth.
If you want to be truly accountable, you'll also note that this
isn't the first time you told me not to make intimate comments
or jokes or to not act like you do with people in private. You'll
do that if you want to be better. Because the first step to improving
is to admit the truth. It will have consequences, but that's
the first step. That's what taking accountability is, Shay. Your
friends who are still with you will make sure it doesn't happen
again. If you really want to, you can even use screenshots. Show
them what happened if you really want. If you really have the
balls to hell, show them the full thing. Show them our confrontation
if you want. You have my full consent. I have nothing to hide
and I'm ready for the consequences of how embarrassing and painful
those exchanges are to read for me.
Okay. If this person, given the first half of this, if this person
is saying this is incredibly embarrassing,
this is going to be some embarrassing. Okay,
this is a complete reaccounting of what exactly went on between
me and Sheay and the direct followout for the people unaware.
Please have the heart to read it in full. It discusses my side
of the truth. I hope everyone who already knows what went down
can take the time to read this in full, too. I've given you the
evidence and condensed version in private. Here you can read
the more in-depth and personal reacounting of the situation alongside
extra parts I might have missed. Shayla TLDDR Shay lied has continued
omitting information and heavily downplayed what actually happened
between me and them. This is behavior they have exhibited with
others too. This was written throughout the 5th of November 2025
to the 9th of November
This document has been edited by Anonymous One with help to remove
any and all identifiers so they can keep anonymous. Important
details that identify me will have to be kept uh in for context,
but as much as possible have been altered to protect my identity.
That being said, any blue text you see has been written by me,
anonymous one. The original document was sent to Sha's private
circles and communities that they were prominent a prominent
part of
those people have full access to all of the personal information
that has been removed in this document. If you did, we should
have all did this really not get leaked. If you are someone who
recognizes the victims, please try to keep them anonymous and
keep it to yourself. They would like their privacy. Please respect
that. Thank you. What actually happened between Sheay and Anonymous
One? Hey, Anonymous One here. I'm sorry it has come to this for
people who are most likely sick of hearing about everything relating
to the situation. Ideally, Shay's accountability statement would
have been the last time you guys would have to hear about it,
but Sheay continues not to properly explain what happened, and
now I'm here having to do it myself. This feels wretched, and
I am afraid. Hold on.
There's an accountability statement. What? Hold on.
Did I miss this? Did I miss an accountability statement? Where's
Where's the accountability statement?
Oh, hold on. This was the accountability statement. I did miss
it. Whoops. Hold
Was this Is this it? This is what Shay told me and my friends
before the doc came out and we banned them instantly.
The doc came out and we banned them
Here is proof that I am the owner of the Discord server and these
are my
Okay. So, he's got a thing. Uh-huh.
Yeah. Brand new animal. F. Ruby and little. I
Okay. I don't dude. I take Kyoko. Okay. Hold on. November 20th,
2025. Shay. Hey, I wanted to post something here before I vanish
for a very, very long time. You are all were very wonderful friends
to me, and I appreciate every ounce of love and care and support
I got from you guys. take care of yourself. But the truth is,
I've made horrible, horrible decisions and have done terrible
things. I've done catastrophic damage to the people I loved,
and this will soon be shown publicly, and that will be the end.
You all deserve to hear from me. I know you will all be betrayed,
hurt, you will all be hurt and betrayed seeing what I had been
doing over the over the years, and I am sorry that uh that I
have inflicted this on you, people who have given me nothing
but kindness. I have serious issues undiagnosed
that has led to an unbelievable disgusting pattern of me seeking
out interactions with friends many of which I met originally
as fans. I abused the trust and love that everyone gave me gave
to me. I abused the platform that everyone gave to me. I abused
the forgiveness and leniency that people gave me. I don't think
I can Okay, wait. Is this not taking accountability?
Wait, where's the further accountability from? I I mind my community
for partners. I think that's disgusting and I'm leaving for a
long time. How is there more accountability
to take from
That's maximum accountability. I've literally never seen an influencer
do that before. Uh actually, I a bunch of people over and I have
no nothing to say in my defense. I'm leaving.
And they're like, "Uh, no, you're not ripped enough yet. Uh,
you thought you could wreck yourself? You thought you could just
yourself like that? No. No, you're not ripped enough yet." Okay,
holding this from the bottom. I don't think I can really put
into words the amount of hurt I've inflicted on the people closest
to me. I don't deserve what I have and I need to sever myself
from the internet while I get help. I start therapy today, but
I have to do this away from the internet and in a place where
I know I can't hurt anyone else. I know you were all you were
so excited to have me here and to get to know me better as a
friend. Frankly, I don't deserve that. The damage I have dealt
into uh into my own community is unforgivable.
How is there more accountability? What did they want?
This is the most I've ever seen somebody
like this is
to be honest. I'm reading some of these statements and I'm like
I think you guys are overplaying your hand. I think this is actually
not anywhere near as bad as you think or seem to be
uh claiming. It does sound like somebody threeing a kid a little
bit like apologizing for it. Like I I I cannot be forgiven for
this. And he's like I'm going to go get therapy. And he's identified
I can't do that while I maintain like a streaming audience. Like
I have a problem. I'm taking advantage of people. I don't know
if it's appropriate to get help for this pro problem while like
staying at the buffet. I'm overeating and I'm I'm sitting at
the buffet. I think I need to remove myself from the buffet to
stop overeating. Is like a good thing to acknowledge and undertake.
Did he like come back and go, "Actually, I don't have a problem.
Actually, I'm not I'm not leaving. I'm not leaving. I'm not going
anywhere." You do that.
I didn't really want to interject as I fear I'm quite blunt,
but I appreciate you giving us some clarification as many of
us were very worried as you've spiraled for the last few months.
A lot of how we view the situation hinged on details we didn't
really have and specific instances of circumstantials, but we
now we know now and everyone can form their perspectives and
process it how they want to. You're undeniably in the wrong and
abusing your platform is just
uh you are undeniably in the wrong and abusing your platform
is just [__] up and plain and simple. But I will
say that recognizing that and thus giving up your platform to
seek proper help away from everything is the first step in the
right direction. And I wish you luck going forward. I know this
will cut deep for a long time. But don't let it you. You deserve
more than that. And you should just help get help so that you
can apologize to those you've hurt regardless of whether forgiveness
will be given or frankly is deserved and then continue on your
own path. Sad to see you go. We all really do love you and are
glad that we got to spend some time with you as a friend. But
I think we all know it'll be a long while before we see you around
again. So, I guess just take care of yourself out there. Use
this as your turning point and don't repeat the past. Good luck
in therapy, Shay. I hope it helps you. I figure you are going
to vanish off of Discord here in the next few hours. So, I'll
let anyone else say their piece if you want to hear it. If you
don't, up to you. I know Ven would probably like to say something
at the very least, but they might DM it or put it in here. Not
sure. They're asleep right now. This is the last image here from
this. I think I appreciate the sentiment. Thank you. The truth
of the matter though is that I have given the people I hurt empty
apologies over and over again and it means nothing. I will never
earn their forgiveness, but I suppose that's part of life. I
had chances to stop this and pick on them. I couldn't stop myself
from continuing even though I knew it was wrong and I knew I
shouldn't be doing it. And my ego got in the way of me getting
help this entire time because it was always so easy to blame
someone else or blame something else or deflect the blame away
or deflect away the blame. I'm entering a hell of my own making,
but I do believe I can get better. I have to. I have never felt
this horrible in my entire life. So guilty over the pain I inflicted
on the people who did nothing but show me love and care. I don't
want to try to obscure the truth or influence how you feel about
me. Though uh though the fact that you can read what I did and
still offer me well wishes speaks volumes to the type of people
you are and I'll value those words. Can't heal a wound without
bleeding first, I suppose.
Oh, hold on. Maybe there are more.
For some reason, it often takes my entire world falling apart
to make a change. I'm not entirely sure what the reason is. Being
dense, egotistical. I think it stems from a deep, deep fear of
being wrong. And I'm so defens. And so I am defensive. I deflect.
I fight tooth and nail over every for any opening I have. And
it leads to situations ballooning wildly out of control instead
of being dealt with while they can still be considered simple
mistakes.
You get one chance to learn the lesson. And it's very telling
that you've decided to take it. And I agree with everyone else.
I hope you get better and can treat every uh treat whoever comes
into your future with a little more kindness. We all do really
care about you regardless of how hurt or betrayed or disappointed
we are. And we still don't even have all the details. Everyone
is going to hit rock bottom at least once, but you can get back
up in
Not in this field. He's He's totally ripped in this. He's never
going to be a YouTuber again after this, right? Okay.
Now, let me go back to the thread.
Hell of a way to sugarcoat it, huh? Okay. To be clear, I would
never be this kind had I known. Please note the time stamps on
the messages. Oh, so hold on. All these messages sound exactly
like the same sound exactly the same as the one they sent me.
They really wanted to sugarcoat this entire thing. WHERE'S THE
SUGAR
WHAT? How could this guy be any more right now?
Where is the sugar coating?
Where is this sugarcoated? Is he worse than the tickler? Yeah,
he is. You all deserve it to deserve to hear it from me. And
they say nothing publicly, preemptively privating their socials
as well. They went dark on us, too. We didn't know Jack until
this morning when they started typing out of the blue. This is
on this two days ago. This is chilling in retrospect. Wait, I
thought they were going to go public.
What
wasn't he like, "Oh, I have to step away and you guys go public
with this." And I'm I'm very confused cuz I don't know why. How
could this guy be any more rich right now? Like, what do they
want?
I I lit I'm literally asking what do they want? Cuz so here's
what I'm seeing is
basically he
didn't post something publicly, right? He did this little miaulpa
in his like friend server and then he privated his socials, but
he's handing you all the things you need to make these allegations,
right? He's literally apologizing to all of these people. He
must understand that these could be used against him. He It's
not like he said, "Oh, I hope you keep this private." He literally
said, "I understand. I [__] up. I'm going."
They needed him to post that publicly. It's not enough that he
handed you all the material to go, "Hey, this is what we don't
like about this guy." Okay. So, then after this, a doc comes
out.
All right. So,
ideally, Shay's accountability statement would have been the
last time you guys would ever need have to hear about it, but
Shay continues not to explain what happened, and now I'm here
having to do it myself. This feels wretched, and I am afraid.
Okay, so basically, they're saying that this guy said he hurt
people really badly, but he's not specific about it. So, now
I have to tell you specifically what it was. I don't know if
he felt like it wasn't going to come out publicly. It seemed
like he was like, "Oh, I'm done. Like, I'm cooked."
We'll see cuz I think the first two I mean, there are assault
allegations definitely. I don't know if he's admitting to those,
but anyway, we'll we'll we'll just keep reading. We have to read
more. We'll understand. Before I begin, I do just I want to just
explain a little where my head is at with all of this. Firstly,
please make sure you are going back to both the videos and the
screenshots and cross referencing as you read to make sure you
are coming to the conclusions you do on the basis of facts and
evidence. I do not expect you to take my word, so please make
sure you are evaluating the conversations themselves to ensure
you know what is happening in full. I mean, you don't have to
do it, but it's probably best you do. Lol. What video? What?
There's a video.
What the video is she talking about? I don't I don't see a video.
Okay. Anyway, secondly, please be aware that my intent isn't
to drive Sha's friends away with this. I am fully aware they
already know of people who know of the situation in full and
are continuing to stick by them, and that is okay. I've said
this to every single person I've told, but I beg of you that
if you stay that you make sure this never ever happens again.
Please take everything I say as an example of what to look out
for and what to call out. Do not let Sheay do this again to anyone.
This the part above is kind of redundant now considering the
scope of Sha's actions. A lot of people have fully cut contact.
I wish it didn't have to be this way and I'm sorry. Don't feel
forced to stay though. Please prioritize your own feelings and
Jesus Christ.
Every single one of these things is like a
like a personal theory on how to handle like any bad thing happening
in your life. They're always like, "Listen, whatever you decide
is fine. I hope you just take care of yourself." Okay. I we need
we could literally just make like a word like if we had not to
airate here we could we could come up with like a blah blah blah
blah statement for this. They could just say blah blah blah blah
and I am being condescending like she is when she does it. Okay.
Like this is this is the same thing that happens in every single
one of these. They do a whole
siloquy on how you should handle personal situations, traumatic
situations, bad situations. And I don't care. just get to the
thing that happened that was bad. For the love of God, I would
also like to make it completely clear. This is my own experience
and any mention of others experiences in any detail will be limited
as much as possible. However, please keep it in mind that countless
people have had their own experiences, whether big or small.
If they wish to use mine as use this as a jumping off point to
talk about their own, they're 100% welcome to. Anything you do
is
Additionally, I would like to note that this to the public that
if your main takeaway from this document is that Shay is a bad
person because they are LGBTQ plus or
that we'd announce your opinion and think you're stupid. Uh,
I think this is definitely there's like some trans brain rot
that crosses over with this that is totally unhealthy and totally
gets excused because trans lives matter like the whole trans
rights movement, right? You guys, you guys definitely protect
some people who are just weirdly like
all of the time and it's it's very consistent and you always
want this clear distinction between your and being trans and
I don't see that that clear distinction. A lot of you guys are
like I fully believe the is a prelude to being trans. Like you
are there is a total like distinct connection there for a lot
of trans people that nobody wants to talk about because they
think it's like unjustifiably pro uh profiling these
I know that's like not popular in general, but that's how I feel
about it. So, so many of the victims are queer or are queer and
neurode divergent. If you use this as an opportunity to spread
hatred to the communities we are a part of, you are not fighting
for the right cause whatsoever. Do not contact or harass Shay.
We don't condone that either. Okay,
let's continue. How has this affected
I originally was going to wait until after until later to explain
how this situation has made me feel, but since starting this
document, I've had a second mental health crisis moment that
was greatly attributed to this entire fiasco. I've had two fits
of hyperventil hyperventilation. Three now as of November 16th.
I've had two fits of hyperventilate. I started hyperventilating
and then I recalled how I was hyperventilating and now it's three.
Now it's three hyperventilating episodes.
When I think about how I was hyperventilating, I start hyperventilating
again. I Okay. Okay,
Since Jay released their most recent statement, I'm currently
writing this on the 6th of November, 2025. So, it has been two
days.
They literally went back to edit.
Like, on November 16th, they had another hyperventilating episode
and they're like, I I have to go update the document. I have
to go. The document needs to know.
Okay. I'm currently writing this on the 6th of November. So,
it's been two days. I actually woke up to that statement being
posted in the early hours of the 5th with no warning. That would
be this statement. Yes. November 20th. No, that's not this statement.
Wait, there's a November 5th statement that I do not have yet.
If anybody knows where the November 5th statement is, I would
like that if you have it, if somebody can grab it.
Okay. But I don't have that one. So,
I've genuinely never felt so much violent stress, such painful
and scary anxiety. I've been through a lot in my life, but this
has to be one of the most gut churning and physically taxing
situations I've ever been through, which says a lot. No, it doesn't.
It sounds like you get this way. Like, literally waking up in
the morning, if you had set an alarm clock, I feel like it traumatizes
you about this much.
Like, this is so over the top. Just so insanely over the top.
I'm not the type of person to buckle physically under stress.
It's usually all in my head. But the digestive issues, the nausea,
the hyperventilation so bad both of my hands have tingled and
my hearing is dulled. The esophagus pain from crying so hard,
the nasal and eye irritation, the heart palpitations. I've struggled
to eat, struggled to get to sleep with pangs of anxiety that
would wake me up as soon as I started to drift off, like my body
was in fight or flight. I've had arguments with my family in
my personal life happen at the same time as this ongoing situation
multiple times. It has been so been intense, and I'm surprised
I'm not in the hospital or phys for physical or mental complications.
I
Man, I don't want to like minimize how stressful stuff like this
could be, but at the same time,
we're like looking into your this is your allegation document.
This is where you get to make your case that this person is bad
and you have spent multip like the entire time not talking about
the situation and what they've done. Right? I am now I'm about
to go into page three of your document and you still have not
said what has happened.
Right? You've just talked about your mental state. That's it.
That's all you've done. Which really just goes to show what you're
doing here,
right? If you That's how I feel about it, man. If you need to
spend, you know,
15 to 20 paragraphs talking about how rough your life is before
you say, "Here's what this guy did."
I I'm sorry. I just like I I stop caring. I think everybody stops
caring. It's not that this doesn't matter. It's Why is this ahead
of any of the allegations you're making? Why? Why is this context
important in any way?
I would love to know because I have no idea.
Mentally, I felt worthless at times. I haven't felt like a person
anymore. There have been so many times I felt disgusted with
my body. Disgusted I was born in the body I was because ah another
trans person.
Another trans person. This is uh this is FTM trans, is it not?
Uh maybe things would be different had I not had I not been perceived
the way it feels I was. Maybe if I was born a man and identified
as a man or overtly masculine at the same time, this would have
never happened. It has made me feel completely unlovable. Someone
who is unable to take affection from anyone out of fear it will
become or against my wishes. Several times I have wished I wasn't
ace.
So none of this bothered me. Not that it would make it right.
Thanks to my OCD, I've been unable to focus on anything other
than this. It's in my mind intrusively constantly. Speaking normally
with friends, spending time with them has been 10x harder. As
a result, Shay has been has made me feel subhuman.
Bro, how up is this guy's life? This guy's life is like a Shakespearean
tragedy. Okay, he is like this total degenerate gooner. He sets
up in like this deviant artcoded degenerate community and then
all of the people he becomes friends with
are a in some way or another. This is like there's like some
entity, some god that's like like Loki, okay, has decided to
make this guy's life chaotic and like devastating personally.
It's like you think you're going to get famous. You think you're
going to get famous and you think you're going to be this this
this stud, but actually everybody around you is going to be a
they're going to be repulsed by you. I got famous. He got rich
and he couldn't find somebody to hang out with that wasn't as
up.
Also, he may be like a consent violating piece of [__]
Possibly if this person could get over talking about their mental
illness, we could actually figure it out. But they won't. They
can't. Thanks to my OCD, I've also been able to unable to focus
on anything other than this. It's in my mind intrusively constantly
speaking with friends. Normally with friends, spending time with
them has been 10 times harder as a result. Um I don't even think
this is OCD. If you have something like this, if you have something
that's like really with you, um that you're upset about, this
is just normal that you're unable to focus on other things. It
keeps intrusively. This is everybody who's ever had like a partner
cheat on them. This isn't OCD. You don't need to des like subscribe
this or ascribe this to some pathology.
Hey, you got cheated on. You've been like betrayed by somebody
in your mind. Yeah, it's going to keep entering your mind constantly.
Oh, I want to take a moment to thank every person who has had
to listen to me cry and sob in voice calls with them. You guys
know who you are and I love you all so much for being there at
my at my very lowest, being there for me at my very lowest because
it was truly at my lowest. Without my friends, I wouldn't be
here. I relive this suffering every single time I talk about
it. Writing this document is actively making me suffer. So I
hope you're happy, Shay, because your of your incompetence, I'm
having to do the thing you're supposed to do, which I asked you
to do a month ago. I can't move on until the score is settled.
So I will settle it myself.
I relive this suffering every Oh, whoops. I'm actually proud
of myself,
Dude, I I swear to God, this is like
This is one, two, three full pages
before. Okay, so where did this start?
This is like where it actually starts is right here. We had three
full pages of this person just arguing about their
identity, their mental illnesses, all their pathologies, their
depression,
Everything. They can't stop you happen. Uh, but I have to keep
going for the sake of other people and to make sure this never
happens again. I'm still going. You cannot stop me from fighting
for myself and others. Okay, so where did this start?
Me and Shay became friends as a result of me being an active
member in their community as far as a fan most prominently during
2023. They messaged me for the first time directly on March 11th,
2023 to thank me for the art I made for them. I was 17 years
old. We quickly quickly grew a friendship through interactions
both in DMs and in gen chat, as well as through the fact that
I was making fan art for them every so often. Bro,
it's the just a robot thing again. again.
Wait,
this person is like making fan art. They're a minor. They go
to like talk, hang out. I Is it just everybody who can draw?
If you like draw things for people on the internet, are you just
Man, there's like there's just a bunch of weird interactions
here. It's like the exact same thing as just a robot. It's very
strange.
We quickly grew a friendship through our interactions both in
DMs and in gen chat, as well as through the fact that I was making
fan art for them every so often. I was added to Trusted on the
27th of June 2023, a bit under a month before I turned 18. Shay
behaved properly while I was underage as far as I'm aware, but
soon after turning 18, my birthday is August 15th, which they
in DMs wish me happy birthday and joked about minors DNI, bro.
Or minors don't do not interact in bio or two.
Uh when dude, do we really have a page of citations? Can I Are
these They're not even links.
Hold on.
Can I get the
screen caps? Control F. Okay. Okay.
So, I was 17 years old at the time.
Thank you for the lovely drawing the other day. Really made my
night.
No problem. I'm glad you liked it and that made your night. It
was fun to draw.
Happy birthday. Thank you, Shay. Got to put the miners DNI in
the bio now. Haha,
Okay. I mean, he's aware you were under 18. Now he's aware you're
18. If you see a total switch up, that would be kind of odd.
It was when they began to use terms like good boy to describe
and praise me. Shay was 24. Okay, so
we see now from after August. This is going to November. Good.
You deserve to. Thank you for real for reaching out. I feel a
lot better now. Good. You deserve
Head pad emote. You should hang out. Need to distract you from
the bad feelings. On my way. Running emoji. Good boy. Haha. Got
him. Damn. Okay. Lauo.
Okay.
Pulling out of the asenold playbook. You love to see it. So,
she was 24. Uh, it was on New Year's Eve of 2023, 31st of December,
after I had vented to Shay about me and my mother's relationship
and how troubled said relationship was that Shay suddenly started
speaking to me out of their abs about oh, about their abs. Four.
I try my best. I'm blunt to a fault sometimes. So, it's taken
years of screaming at each other and lots of blank scared emoji
to get to a point where we're in therapy and we're starting to
get better at sorting things out. Thanks for letting me vent
to you a bit. I feel a lot better now. I feel a bit better now.
Headp emoji. Anytime. I care about you a lot, dork. You scringle.
By the way, if you ever need to vent, my DMs will always be here
if you need it. Gr. I'm so mad about how well my career is going
and my bank account status. Gr. And I'm mad that I have a fat
ass. I have nothing to be mad about lately. Life has been good.
This is not dude this is not that I understand it's like weird
but bro I'm guessing okay maybe this is if he always talks as
in a totally like platonic fashion with everybody but I'm guessing
at some point in this I'm going to see some absolutely wretched
disgusting like gay thing going on right I feel like that's almost
certainly going to happen at some point here
I feel like him him when he's being is going to be so much different
from who he is when he's just being like cute and that is there's
going to be such a huge distinction, but we'll see. Their message
was in direct rel relation to me offering to listen to them vent
and they proceeded to send me a screenshot of someone's Twitter
header. This was header was consider consisted of Sha's GDQ badass
picture. They told me that I used my platform to force my friend
to make this her banner for the entire
Uh what dude? Everything I hear is just goofy. Okay, so here's
the picture of them on a bed showing their ass. So they laugh
at the app picture. I'm glad that things are going well for you,
bestie. I hope they continue that way because you deserve it.
I use my platform to force my friend to make this her banner
for the entire year. Embelay trans. Bro, this guy is the most
disgust
Why?
Why? If you're a trans person, this guy's so clearly got a fetish.
Why are you hanging out with him? What do you think?
This is like
if I had like a fetish for Asian girls and I ran like
what do Asian girls like? Like a sushi comparison community or
something. Okay, I don't know. I literally don't know. But I
I I made some community that caters to people in that fetish
group and then I clearly everybody in that fetish group and then
you were somebody in that fetish group and I started talking
to you. Wouldn't you be a little concerned that I'm like that
like it's going to be for with a like goal? Boba boba tea appreciation.
Okay, sure. I don't even know, dude. But I'm just saying that
like
everybody this guy's friends with is trans. Isn't that like concerning?
Anyway, godamn you got dumpy. You know it. I'm hot as [__]
and I know it. Hey, save some for the rest of us. You can't handle
all that genderful dumpy for yourself. That is a sentence I just
typed. Are you saying you want to have a fat ass?
Mm. Actually, that implies I don't have a fat ass already. Proof.
Okay, that's that's
But what is the pro? They're both flirting. They're both flirting.
This is like a totally normal. This is the most restrained. This
guy's borderline. You know what I'm concerned about is this guy
might be masquerading as a chaser cuz this is the most restrained
like
the most restrained
I've ever seen a person in DMs. It's disgusting cuz it's like
childlike and weird and playing on this like innocence thing.
I don't believe any of them have, but this is the least like
deviant messages I've ever read for a persistent period from
somebody who's like a trans chaser. Why has a minor mentioned
your app in any context? She's not a minor at this point, is
she?
I thought she was I thought she turned 18
Yeah, she's 18 at this point.
She's not even a minor anymore. Right. And there I don't even
think there's allegations of like grooming here. I mean, they
had a friendship, but I don't see it being And they said that
he wasn't before she turned 18. So, like, maybe there's something,
but it was like a couple months before she turned 18 that she
sent Bannard.
I I assume if there was like something working towards that kind
of
that there'd be more context here. Maybe frightened cuz this
screenshot is dark
blank apps. Oh, sorry. I need to read whatever seven's a part
of.
Okay. I was aware this was stupid to say. It's not really something
I like to joke about. She So, hold on. We looked at five. I'm
going to start reading from right after five.
I started to respond to this playfully, saying dumb like, "Godamn,
you got dumpy." I was aware this was a stupid to this was stupid
to say. It's not really something I like to joke about often,
but it felt right in the moment given how playful Shay can be.
I wanted to be friends with them, so I wanted to match the energy.
This though ended up being ended up with Shay saying, "So, you're
saying you want to have a fat app?" and my response of that implies
I don't already have a fat apt. This is where proof question
mark was asked by sheay six additional context for this public
version of the doc. This specific nickname is a play on words
related to anonymous one's name. We are not redacting the entire
section because it adds important context to the this
I don't know why she focused on the nickname blank apps for the
segment. For those unaware, blank apps was a nickname I gave
myself in Sha sub only Minecraft server using a sign next to
my bed in game. I would tell my friends at the time, people I
had known for longer than Sheay, and testify themselves not to
call me that name as part of the joke, not to call me that name
as part of the joke. It always was always don't call them name
after in 2023. I know that for
So, you had a name that you used on a sign in Minecraft that
people aren't supposed to use for you. Okay.
I must note however that in recent years, so post 2023 8 known
arrow person blanks has been in several relationships. Okay.
Blank proving he is a freak entrusted today. The misadventures
of blanks. Congrats blank apps. Hi Blanks. Okay.
Uh I definitely started joking more openly about the name. Now
I cannot prove myself that this conversation didn't happen in
2023. It's extremely hard to prove a negative. But if it did
happen, then the most likely reason Shay cannot find evidence
for it is either that is that it either happened in a voice call
or in Twitch chat. I implore Shay to search the frog in the family
discord for the name blank app to find if they believe it to
be true that I it happened in a public chat. Once again, completely
possible it happened off-handedly in Twitch chat or VC, but considering
context, quite strange. It would be the focus point Shay used
instead of the actual reason the conversation started.
Okay, hold on. Wait, I'm I'm so confus I'll be real. I'm so confused.
Did I miss something here? Did I miss like a whole section of
this document that should have been read before? Cuz I swear
I like I went and looked at this. I thought from the beginning
proof. And then
there's all of this stuff.
What am I missing?
We're all reading this at the same speed.
I don't know why Shay focused on the nickname blank ass for the
segment. Is this referring to like, oh, I forced my friend with
a platform to change their [__] to this or something,
bro? What the are they talking about? They're like not explaining
at all. What segment? The nickname name app for this segment.
For those unaware, name was a nickname. Oh, is this in his response
or something?
So, again, we've apparently got a response from him where I don't
see the response from him. Can I
How do we find this? Hold on. I'm I'm looking on Twitter. Okay,
Twitter's going to break. Very cool. Very cool. Very cool. Very
trying to find where where the could this guy be? Okay. No, I
do see some very degenerate DMs from this guy. Jesus Christ.
Okay. I
I just searched and I spoiled some stuff for myself. Very funny,
but I don't I don't know. We'll just keep reading. I don't care
anymore. Okay. Shay goated the conversation on after I explained
and they joked about my body. This went on until I finally said
I did have a photo that could show what I meant using the angle
and it was it was taken from. This image was of me in my Amorei
hoodie, something I had posted everywhere. I think I actually
posted it in Frog Family's photo channel. They didn't know this
yet, though, and I gave them an out since I was confused and
unsure on if I should actually post the image or not. Deep down,
I wanted to tell them not to do so. I uh not or them to tell
me not to so I didn't have to. I had even asked my own mother
what I should do in this situation when I'm unsure about sending
something with this context uh with this context around it. She
didn't encourage me not to. So, I felt like I had to. I wanted
Chay to like me, but I wanted them to be happy
or and I wanted them to be happy. So, when they saw my hesitance
responding to my butt with a but what, I felt even more inclined
to send it. I'm a small beam pole so my ass is probably not that
big. Lol. I'm just a little guy. Now you're packing. Yeah, I
totally I have the biggest ass known to man. blank 100% real.
Uh I definitely I believe it. I swear to God this is going to
end up with you taking a picture of your ass and it's going to
end up looking like one of those RZ memes. Lauo, I do actually
have a photo of me turned to the side showing off my Amori hoodie
but flustered emoji. But what?
This is flirting. This is totally normal flirting
um amongst like
art Discord. Like this is this is not special. This is not him
pressuring you. In fact, this has a totally like playful contact,
like playful feel to it. It doesn't feel remotely like you're
But flustered emoji. This is like flirting.
This is what it is.
And if it's not like totally normal, I can't see how he's supposed
to know that. Okay. Anyway, and your mom literally apparently
didn't tell you not to send it. What?
They are lucky I didn't send anything suggestive. They were completely
irresponsible. I was young. It was 4 months after I turned
Wait, what would have been the problem?
You're 18. What would be the
what? Huh?
Why do they scribble the emojis? I'm guessing the emojis prove
like categorically who it is. Like they're probably related maybe
to their own Discord. They're their own emojis. They've drawn
emojis like for a character they use, right?
I'm guessing that's how it is. So to add salt to the wound, they
blame me for the conversation even starting. I called this out
as projection jokingly because to some extent I think it was
what? Okay, you defin got something going on there? Also, yeah,
it's a cute hoodie. Lauo, how the [__] did we end
up having an discussion? Lauo, we are unhinged. I used my platform
to force my friend to make this her banner for the entire year.
Oh. Ah, so you're blaming me. I don't think that's fully accurate.
I think you wanted a chance to flex, too. I see through your
faint bestie. You cannot fool me. Uh, it is weird that he is
like a 23-year-old calling like
unironically freshly 18-year-olds his bestie that he's only known
for like a year. Actually, I think like six months at this point.
Is that is that right? When did they meet? She did a timeline.
Oh, it's not on this document though. It's on this document.
Second. Oh, we're on page what? Four there. So, they met
When were you born?
What?
Born a man, born this. I was born late November 2004 and they
started talking here.
Oh, I was friends with Shay for a few years starting in early
2022.
Oh, no. This Sorry, this is Aspen. I went to a different one.
Hold on. Written statement. My birthday is August
>> Okay, so
just took $5. I'm a transistic
fluid pediexual
of a force server pronouns boom slay now
let's boundary play okay can you chill you chill thank you for
the donation whatever that voice was never use that again that
voice was terrifying
what the was that voice
okay so her birthday was August August 15th and they started
talking in 2023.
Most prominently during 2023, March 11th, 2023, she messaged
him or they messaged
them for the fan art. Okay, so this is only we're looking at
the screenshots. These were actually only from a few months later.
I got to one >> I'm recording this
November 18th of
If you're seeing this, there has been an exposure document released
about Sheay, who you might know as the popular Undertale series
content creator. They have done completely reprehensible things
to their friends and loved ones, and many people that I know
have been affected by their horrible actions.
These are chronicled in a document posted in the description.
Just a fair warning for anyone that goes to read it. It accounts
for events such as
assault,
abuse, verbal abuse, grooming,
and a number of other horrible
things. So, I'm just laying that out for anyone that is sensitive
to those kinds of things.
I have been in the know about these actions for the past uh I
want to say uh 28
hours.
And uh before learning about this uh they were someone that I
considered a
reading everyone's testimonies
and the events that were shown in the
seeing how they were affected by Sha's
>> has just completely shattered my trust. >> I just
went and grabbed water from my kitchen. Just give me a second.
It is horrific.
Which is the whole reason why I'm >> Dude, it's so awful
when you're sick
and you like try drinking water and you're always dehydrated.
No matter how much water you drink, you're just always dehydrated
automatically forever.
Hope Chud covers this drama. Chud did cover this drama.
Chud threw out some crazy slurs covering this drama. But I'm
starting to understand. I got linked a clip of Chud covering
this drama and he started dropping
and the fs slur. I I didn't understand and now I'm starting to
get it a little bit. Okay. I not that I condone it. I just I'm
starting to get it. It's making some sense. It's kind of [__]
up.
Okay. We need to go back. Where were we? We're around here. All
right.
What do
Okay. Projection. They teased me asking me what I was going to
do about it. I joked about chasing them around at GDQ one someday.
Something I found funny to do with my tall friends. Picturing
a height person. A height person chasing someone down tall down
a hallway sounds stupid as hell. What height?
Uh, and they told me they would hug me and pick me up.
Ch activated his tracer rage. I think I think Chud probably just
had flashbacks. Okay. 17-year-old trans people trying to cancel
somebody. Uh-uh. No. No. No. No. No, no, no, no. Not on my watch.
Never again. It's like his holocaust. Okay. Never again. Never
forget and never again. Both. These 17-year-old trans people
have had enough. I've had enough of them. Okay. They censored
height for some reason. Oh,
picturing a 5'4 person chasing someone down a hallway. Sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure.
So, 11.
Okay. Scrunky. People think my ass is edited because I got mad
dumpy. You can't project your flexing onto me. Yes, I can. I
just did. What are you going to do about it? Huh?
SGDQ2024.
Picture the scene. You're walking down a hallway when all of
a sudden there are tiny tippy tap footsteps of a blank speeding
in your direction. I will hug them and pick them up. Boom. You
can't stop me. You know I will. Okay.
I Dude, I
What? There's just something very wrong in a ve in a general
sense. There's just something very wrong with pretending to be
like little kids all the time. I'm sorry. It's just weird. Especially
once things become I don't know how you separate it, right? This
is bizarre. Very bizarre behavior. This entire thing has been
a a masterclass in
weirdo
degenerate behavior
already and we haven't gotten anything
Okay, that was one of many exceptions I made for Shay. So they
told me they would pick me, hug me and pick me up. That was one
of many exceptions I made for Shay. Usually, these things included
more intimate or affectionate things like calling me cute. I
hated anyone calling me this, but I made exceptions for them
specifically. It made me feel special. I felt important to them.
The same goes for being picked up. I've openly discussed before
how I'd hate the idea of being picked up. It's something people
used to do without my consent throughout my childhood because
of my height, which resulted in me being spun around and tossed
like a doll, but it's entirely possible Shay didn't see it. It's
the least of my concerns nonetheless. But I thought I it would
be important to note my own pattern of allowing Shay to do things
I wouldn't allow others to do. I drew art for them for free when
they asked, which they made into their profile picture for the
month of October 2024.
During a time where I had halted
during a time where I had halted drawing for people when they
asked, even when payment was given, another example of an
Uh, I just don't fulfill my commissions. And I made excuses to
people in October 2024. And I don't want them to think that I
was drawing normally cuz I listen, this was my trauma that made
me do this. Okay, good one. Another example of an exception I
made for them. I finished it the same day. She actually wasn't
the nicest to me about the artwork. 56. But apologized the next
day after I confronted him them about how it hurt my feelings.
Hold on. We go down to 12. How much do I have to uh do I have
to look at you cutely for a PFP featuring witch clothes? You
want a spooky PFP? Is there anything Is there any particular
images of said witch clothes I could look at? Maybe just the
hat. I think I'd look cute in a black turtleneck hat plus purple
hair. Though you can do whatever. I just want something spooky.
I shall see what I can
Okay. Uh, and then hold on. It was what?
56. What did he say? Oh, Jesus. I'm curious. What's up with the
left shoulder? I typically like to angle the shoulders like that
so it looks less boring pose-wise. It's hard to explain. Imagine
the camera's to the right of you in the art and you're looking
to the right. The right shoulder is going to be cut off in the
PFP circle. So, I was just wondering because it even goes behind
the hand. I see the vision. Just makes it me look like a linebacker.
Got them huge ass shoulders.
Hold on. Let me finish processing this speed paint and I'll try
to show it better. I just think it would look better in the circle
PFB if the shoulder angle was just generic, for lack of a better
word. It shows that it better. Spooky. I'm spooky. I mean, I
don't think this them not being like, is this person not trans
or something? It seems like they're trying to be more feminine
presenting, right, in stuff.
Is that not Is that Is that not like them just trying to be respected
as someone who wants to be like fem presenting? They don't want
shoulders that make them feel masculine and they're like getting
they're they're feeling like their profile pictures make them
look masculine. Isn't that something you should respect as like
a trans person? Feel like it is. Anyway, Shay actually wasn't
the nicest to me about the artwork. 56. But apologized next day
after I confronted them about how it hurt my feelings. Power
imbalance played a big played big on my reactions to Shay doing
these things. I was more hesitant to say no to upset to confront.
These are all things I have always struggled to put boundaries
up with uh put boundaries up for most of my life. She has always
been in the back of my mind when making decisions relating to
them. I felt I owed it to them with how often they told me how
close we were and how they much they trusted me. It was something
they told me a lot enough for it to be something I remember so
much. This bracketed section was added after finishing the dock
whilst reading it back. I completely forgot to mention that this
was not the only time Sheay made this exact proof question mark
joke to me in relation to seeing my app. In the early hours of
the 27th of March 2024, Sheay started streaming Stardw Valley
on their Shay 2 account. In this stream, in this stream chat,
I remember mentioning the new this New Year's incident to them
and tagged back to the joke I had made to them uh made back then.
Shay proceeds to respond proof again to me during the stream.
I responded back linking back to proof I had sent and showed
them an image of an LPS toy I had when reaching within reaching
distance because I didn't want to take another photo. Shay never
directly responded after this. And I know for a fact it was during
the stream because I was act I actively sent them Stardw Valley
wiki information unprompted implying I was sending this as a
result of the stream which again Shay doesn't respond to in DMs.
Hold on. 82. I'll be playing more Stardw later if you need something
to relax a bit. I'll be there. Good lord. I have too many Theorian
friends. I was just about to say good boy without thinking. Lau
83.
Yeah, I have the biggest known to man. 100% real. You silly proof.
You're poof. I do not have any more photos of myself with this
angle. You get him instead. It's a picture of like something
or scroll. How's the sleep schedule? Okay,
bro. Did this guy get like totally cancelled for nothing?
What the are we doing here? That's like wild. Okay, hold on.
We need to go back to this screen.
This here's where we are. Did we read 13? We did not. Hold on.
No, I really appreciate you take the time to word things in an
explanatory way. I have a lot of trust in you. Hold on. Wait,
what?
Oh, so this is how the praise like made him made them feel like
they were beholden to him.
Okay,
I really appreciate you taking the time to word things in an
explanatory way. I have a lot of trust in you and your understanding
and respect towards more serious things is a part of the reason
why. I really appreciate that. I always feel really comfortable
talking to you. I consider you one of my closest friends and
you're one of the few people I have absolute confidence confiding
in in less words. You're awesome.
You don't need to have you need don't need any of those things
to fit in. You fit in just by being you and by being awesome.
And you're not smart enough. You're one of the smartest people
I know. And I appreciate your sensitivity. By the way, this is
like I'm sorry, none of these people are this awesome. It's weird
to just gas people up on nothing, right? It's It usually helps
if you can name like actual things they're doing, actual things
they've done that make you appreciate them, make you love them.
You gas them up on nothing, it it stops working after a while.
Feels like very bizarre. Yeah. I don't know. It's very weird.
Okay. Anyway, we continue. Why was I afraid to speak up about
Sheay? There is a situation I will not give details about that
occurred in late 2024 that involved me finding out about a dynamic
between Shay and someone else that was the nature. That person,
victim number seven, dude,
wait, we we're on victim number one. That's victim number seven
came to me in confidence about their feelings. And because of
the guilt of keeping my knowledge of it from Sheay and my wanting
to help in sorting this situation out as someone who cared about
both of them as friends, I told them what I knew. The reason
The reason I specifically bring this up is because Sha's reaction
to me knowing this information was one of the big reasons I was
so terrified to confide in anyone about our interactions both
in the past and present. They repeated to me that the interactions
they had were personal and private, cited how it would have made
them made me uncomfortable to read them because I'm arrow and
said it was it made them uncomfortable that the person in question
came to me. They knew I was close with came to me. They knew
I was close with without their consent instead of talking to
other people. 14.
The person uh this is about is giving me consent to share the
screenshot and speak about what I have. Yeah, definitely blank,
which I get. I understand that. At the same time, it does make
me uncomfortable that this was brought up to someone blank knows
I'm close with without my consent instead of talking to me. Blank.
Okay,
brother. The situation was in the back of my mind until the most
recent incident. It plagued me in a way because I knew deep down
that the 2023 New Year situation was wrong and I kept linking
the two situations, wondering if Shay saw our relationship in
a similar way. I had not enough reason to think about I had not
enough reason to think properly think this through. think this
though and tried to forget about it completely. 2023 New Year
situation
is that that isn't with them. That's is this saying that it's
the star person?
Dude, what the
2023 New Year's situation? When did when did they talk to
Bro, this is becoming like a swamp that I am having a hard time
understanding.
2023 New Year's situation. This person started talking to him
in not not New Year's 2023. who is um the star person to talk
to him in 2022
and the Oh, the Aspen. Aspen person, not Star. This is like Aspen.
Hold on. Let's go. Let's just go down in the screenshots. This
is a way better way to lay this out. By the way, doing the linking
thing is so stupid. Doing like the Oh, I'm going to do my own
little like side. No, every time you reference something, just
put the screenshot in. There's no reason to do it the way you're
doing it. It's like so
Okay. Anyway, let's go to New Year's 2023. Could it be this person
or?
Nope. Doesn't seem that way. Seems like there's a big gap in
the DMs here. Okay, someone else.
They might be referring to victim number seven. Hold on. If we
go to this, is there a victim number seven here? Anonymous number
seven.
Ah, nope. This is
January 30th.
Okay, whatever. We'll figure it out as we go. There will be more.
We'll understand it eventually. We'll get it. We'll get it. I
swear we'll try to get it. We'll try our best. Okay,
The reason I specifically bring this up is Shay's reaction. The
information is one of the biggest reason. Oh, there's a situation
I will not give details about that occurred in late 2024 that
involved me finding out about a dynamic between Shay and someone
else that was in nature. Oh no, we did this all already. Okay.
Okay. Chay had a pretty large paranoia and trauma over people
talking behind their back/ve posting and expressed this to me
multiple times during our friendship. When I was vague about
things that were bothering me to them, they would pry to try
to get it out of me. 15. Nope.
God, this is the worst layout for a document. I'm struggling
to phrase it without explicitly telling you it what it's about,
and I'm not sure it's my place to do that. It's complicated,
but I can say that you can relax because and that you're not
in trouble. Autism to autism communication. How the do you write
a sentence? H. You're going to try and guess what it is, aren't
you? I mean, I already am subconsciously thinking about what
it could be. Hey, there's this really bad thing that happened
with you, but I can't tell you about it. Uh, I'm going to use
my incredible understanding of autism to guess that you're trying
to guess what it is, cuz I told you it's a bad thing. Yeah. No
[__]
Obviously.
[__] you doing, bro? Okay. Shay made it a point to
tell me multiple times that I would scare them with my vaguess,
asking if it was ever about them. 16. Are you okay? Sorry, I
got a little anxious earlier because of your tweet on alt. I
know it's not about me, but my brain is stupid sometimes. Anxiety
sucks. Fun fact. I'm sorry for worrying you. There's stuff I
can't really go into detail on because I'm an outsider and it's
not my place. But otherwise, I would have confided in you about
the subject. Plus, I'm not in a good place mentally to really
be talking about it anyway because of how my IRL situation has
been. So, I wouldn't handle it well anyway. complicated stuff.
You're all good. Just know that. Just know that. Does it have
anything to do with me? I mean, maybe you could argue there's
a guilty conscience.
Yeah. No. Yeah, that's fair. But also, holy [__]
Lol. Uh, next time, please say something like, "It's something
you probably know about, but you're not involved with, and you
were giving me a heart attack. I'm already definitely anxious
about people secretly speaking negatively of me behind my back.
I'm trying to get better about that, but old wounds, they sting.
The old wounds, they sting."
Okay. All right. All right.
Uh, let's see. What are we What are we doing here? Are we test?
Are we still live, guys? What's going on?
Are we Are we not feeling this? It feels like um
This is a lot of reading.
I'm here. You guys need to chat. I think we're hitting the the
kick thing. Just need to start chatting. Okay, just throw a couple
chats in. Throw Just throw Hello. Hello. Are you there? Are you
there? Hello. Throw a couple chats in. Kick is doing a thing
now where if you don't chat, they they take you out of the viewer
count. So, you got to chat. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I need to actually
prompt you guys to chat. All right. Once in a while.
Love you. Thank you. Oh, did I just No.
Hold on. I know where I am. I know where I am.
Right here. Okay. We're good. We're
Engagement baiting. I have to engagement bait once in a while.
I I do.
the kick sort of optimizing against We could do like a stream
for chat interaction, but unfortunately that's just like a totally
different stream. It kind of it's kind of annoying to be honest
with you. But we're good. We're
Sometimes I don't particularly want to tell. So he basically
he's just he's like, "Oh, I'm really worried that somebody's
talking about me behind my back." I understand that, I guess,
but it's also weird if it was in kind some kind of context. He
might have some concern. What are people saying about me? What
are people doing? It's very, very odd. Sometimes I didn't particularly
want to tell Shay how I was feeling or what was bothering me,
but I always found myself doing it when they cried. I couldn't
bring myself to tell them no. It felt bad for me. It felt bad
to tell them no. This also obviously didn't help with what I
said previously about my fear of telling other people the things
they had done to me. They had trauma about their friends going
behind their back. If I confided in people in private about how
uncomfortable they made me feel,
something would happen. That's a sentence that goes nowhere.
A sentence to nowhere.
Thanks. Where too? I would be triggering their trauma if they
ever found out. It was unsettling and guiltridden feeling. I
told myself multiple times when bad things happened that I wouldn't
tell anyone that maybe I'd have to take this to the grave with
me. I wanted to be a loyal and good friend and uh loyal and a
good friend. And honestly, this entire situation made has made
me feel like the worst person alive because of this. In the present,
I can safely say I've carried guilt for months. I feel like a
monster, especially now this is going public.
Shay and other people's hair. Something I've leed against my
will during the situation is that Sheay has a thing for long
hair. Why is this relevant? December 2nd of 2024, Sheay had spoken
to me about how they had gotten a new hairdryer in which they
told me, "If that gives you ideas,
tongue face." What?
My hair has gotten really soft since I got my new haird dryer.
Oh, hell yeah. That gives you ideas. The floof. That reminds
me I should probably cut my hair shorter at some point. Your
hair looks so amazing, though. It's up to you, of course. I'm
just a big fan of cute boys with long hair. That's very based.
I think boys with longer hair look cool, too.
Okay.
Damn, what a monster.
Uh, anytime or sorry, at the time, I had no clue what that meant.
So, I paid it no mind. if I had mentioned to them that I wanted
to cut my hair shorter because it helps with my gender dysphoria.
I think everyone knows I'm trans, lol. And to my surprise, Shay
responded with, "Your hair looks so amazing, though. Like, they
didn't want me to cut it." This was confusing to me because Shay
knows I'm trans. Again, literally everyone does. It's strange,
but nothing heinous about without the context that I know. To
give them credit, they told me it was my own choice. That was
fine. But the thing is, okay, the thing is when he was like,
"Hey, you're making my my shoulders look really masculine and
that makes me feel bad." When he said that, you didn't give a
You're like, "Oh, he's actually really rude to me." But now you're
trans mask, so you're like trying to be masculine as a born female
person. You're trying to be, you know, be a man, be mask passing
or whatever, male passing, right?
And you you had none of that concern for him. But when he says,
"Oh, I like guys with long hair." You're like, "Oh, well, this
is weird." You're making me feel really weird.
That doesn't feel fair. Context is that they have a thing for
longer hair and that seems to be known to people who have had
intimate relations with them. It was news to me until like a
month ago and was pretty horrifying to find out. This is the
exact same fear I had with my ex-boyfriend that he was being
subtle about being uh something he had a kink over and that our
innocent and personal conversations were being used to satiate
his desires.
Okay. Really?
I mean, maybe. I guess he says, "If that gives you ideas,
but but dude, this is such a reach, man. If that gives you
my hair's gotten really soft." If that gives you ideas,
I don't I Okay.
we continue.
I was pretty upset to find this out. And while it may not have
uh mean anything to most, it means a [__] ton to
me. No wonder Sheay said, "If that gives you ideas, it all makes
sense to me. It all makes sense to me now." Additionally, after
this happened, Sheay offered to let me run my hands through their
hair and then proceeded to cat post. Lovely. Other people can
corroborate with Shay that Shay says similar things and does
similar things with other people, especially people they wish
to be intimate or actively are intimate with. Hi. Honestly, your
hair's texture is really awesome. It's very poofy.
Very base. I think boys with longer hair look cool, too. Hi.
Honestly, your hair's texture is really awesome. It's very poofy.
You're absolutely free to run your hands through it. Not to cat
post on me, but laps are comfy. Headp emoji. You're absolutely,
dude.
Absolutely free to run. Yeah, ditto. Cuz it's nice when people
play with my hair. Okay.
I'm not reading this. I'm not reading this. I'm not doing it.
No shot. No way. Not doing it.
Absolutely not. Absolutely no. Okay. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No wonder. Shay said that uh if we are done with this, did anything
weird ever happen in trusted chat? Trusted chat was the channel
a channel in Sha's discord comprising about 35 plus of Sha's
friends and frog family. Only people with the idiot role could
see the #rusted channel along with a couple other channels such
as #vent. In 2023, I was added to the trusted to trusted as an
artist that Shay considered a friend. Typically, people were
added who Shay met with uh from their server/ community and wanted
to get closer to. But as the years went on, it became a channel
that really only that only really ever added friends of friends.
If you can find the odd examples of Shay misbehaving and being
trusted chat, I think everyone is guilty of having those moments
despite the fact we had children there. We had children there.
Okay. I'm going to mention this specific instance though because
I remember it extremely clearly and have evidence to prove it
happened. 19. Okay. Six screen caps. Scroll down for more examples
on the next page.
Never really understood, dude. This is just going to again I
want to know who this the person I could not do something without
being friends with this person with the person being able to
trust them knowing their maturity
who's participating in this conversation. I always hesitated
to say I'm on the ace spectrum because like I enjoy stuff lol
but Demi fits me very
Demi feels right for me. I'm comfortable in that kind. I'm such
a for making sure boundaries are respected. Hey me too w
this is the gayest thing minor number one. Hi. Meanwhile, I cannot
imagine not at least doing every that every once in a while.
Like, seriously, do people enjoy it?
Consent is very hot, dude. This is so gross. So gay. I'm sorry.
This is just weird. This whole conversation is weird. I just
like I just need to be friends with people. I'm going to talk
about this in my in my server channel with a bunch of like miners
in it. Yep. Yep. It's like not even bad because they're minors
there. It's just like It's all weird. It's all just weird. I
don't know how to There's not like something morally bad about
this conversation happening with a kid around. Look, man, call
me a slave to evolution, I guess.
Oh, never mind. Now they're talking
Meanwhile, uh, and that is a very big
Somebody else cut off here. That's got to be him still, right?
A little bit later. Wacky one. Very wacky. A bigger a bigger
butt than Shay. Look, man, call me a slave to evolution. Yes.
I don't think it's weird. It's just tmi. It's nothing bad. Just
like if you don't want to know. I don't think I've ever been
horny in my entire life. And I'm glad cuz it sounds terrible.
I would rather die. Actually,
N you're you're not weird. Who are who you are? That's okay.
Wait. I think it's weird. It's just who you are and that's okay.
Some people just don't have a drive for that kind of stuff. There's
nothing wrong with you. Hell, I respect it. Lead message by Shay.
Just something along the lines
of I do not have any pressure to perform in that way in a relationship
and that's nice. Bro, what the [__] Why is this in
this document
It's like not even that far outside of the norm. It's like not
that weird.
It's like weird. It's It's weird in a different way. It's like
this is so much more tame the whole time. It's so much more tame
than anything I'm expecting to see in this entire thing.
Anyway,
December 6th of 2024, a conversation was had about in the vent
channel. Me and others were participants in this conversation,
which I'm aware I shouldn't have been partaking either, but al
someone who also was a participant with Shay. And what's worse
is that there is proof that two minors saw these messages and
were present lurking. Both of them were 17.
Okay, that isn't even necessarily bad. Okay, I'm going to go
ahead and say it. That's not even necessarily bad. Do you think
17-year-olds don't consume media that talks about Do you think
17-year-olds don't have conversations with people about it's
not them? Nobody is mining them for details around how they Nobody's
doing anything like that. It didn't look inappropriate at all.
It looked totally fine. And I say that as somebody who thinks
you're all weird degenerates. Probably them being in that channel
seems terrifying to me.
But like that didn't seem like an overtly like conversation.
It It was like almost just an It wasn't that bad. It wasn't a
conversation that couldn't take place in a PG movie,
right? If if people were encouraging them to participate, if
people were tagging them and trying to get them to participate,
that would be weird. But from what I saw, it was just them like
coming in once in a while and like seeing being like, "Hi,
hold on. Wait, what is this?" Some people don't have a drive
for that stuff. There's nothing wrong with you. Hell, I respect
it.
Nothing. You're pog champ. Um,
well, Shay, oh, just something along the lines of I do not have
any pressure to perform in the in that way in a relationship
and that's nice. So, I don't have to do stuff in a relationship
and that's nice.
Lau Shay Shay, what the did that mean? Good one, Shay. You can't
just go out and say that minor number two.
That word was not there. I I can't see something that is wrong.
Rate this from zero to Colleen Ballinger. It's like.5. I have
no doubt that this guy could get weird with minors. He's like
seems like a total weirdo. He acts like a kid. He seems to He's
like got Peter Pan syndrome or something, but I don't see it
happening here. This specific conversation is not weird. It's
not like totally out of bounds. It doesn't seem like it's that
off.
I I can't be alone on an island here. Like it's it's weird to
have these talks, right? It's it's odd.
Yes, is a good word. It is odd, but it is not like
degenerate to have these kinds of talks, bro.
Okay. I hate to reference food shops shortly after we did what
uh shortly after earlier when Ral linked the tweet, but didn't
food shops have way more suggestive conversations with an actual
minor than this person did?
Like, wasn't food shops sending pictures of herself to an actual
minor?
Am I crazy? I remember Aiden looking through these screenshots
a while back. I'm almost positive that this happened and this
guy's like quitting. Anyway, it's fine. Whatever. I have to ask
how the was this allowed and why the did nobody stop this conversation.
This should never have been normalized and I'm sickened with
myself for not putting a stop to to a stop putting it a stop
to it. I had a feeling it was wrong but went along with it because
everyone else seemed fine with it. Especially the server owner
main figure Shay.
This is so
gross. So
this is just wretched behavior, right? Oh, well um uh I know
I thought it was wrong, but the server owner was like, "No, we
should have these conversations with kids." So, I went along
with it. How does this help you?
How does this help? I don't see how this helps. Seems goofy.
Uh as of writing this, the idiot role entrusted still exists.
So, what is the was the most recent example of Shay's behavior?
All right, we're on to the interaction that actually sparked
my need to talk to Shay about talk about Shay's behavior to other
people between May 7th and May 8th of 2025. This happened at
night, so I carried from one day to the next in my time zone.
For everyone else, this would have just been May 7th. I had responded
to Xander's usual hello bottoms in my iPhone message. Hello bottoms
in my iPhone message. So as so 20 for the as so 20 for the obvious
reason that I do not identify with the label bottom. I've never
personally jived with the idea of being labeled as such. And
it is something that Shay has tried to playfully argue I am since
we became
Okay, 20. We going down to 20 here. Hello bottoms of my iPhone
and blank and blank and at self.
So with the blue, this would be anonymous number one, right?
Freaky blue freak freaky person. Okay, turning into this that
ain't happening. That's what they all say now. I'd be pretty
uncomfy if I tried to be like blank like in the bottom overly
talking about women's sense. Um, that just ain't me. Oh, don't
worry. I could literally never see you doing that, Lau. I was
simply gesting.
It was simply a joke.
Uh, they even once teased I was becoming like redacted one who
regularly got called a bottom. It's like so they so badly wanted
me to be someone I am not, and that always made me feel somewhat
uncomfortable. I tried my best to push against this when I could.
Anywh who or anyhow soon after I responded, Shay teased that
I was the bottom for whatever reason. This prompted me to tease
them back about a tweet I had made on my private Twitter. 22.
So fantastic I have to make this unprivate to prove what happened.
Um uh-huh. You think I'm a bottom? Laughing. Someone hasn't seen
that one tweet I made that one time recently.
Swinging onto the back of a fanboy and giving him a hickey of
a lifetime like a little vampire on top of his upper trapezius
where the neck and the shoulder connect. That area is something
I I'll probably never do, but it sounds
Okay. Why? Okay. I don't
Weird. All just very weird.
Links it to him. This is embarrassing, but oh well. Hey, Lau.
Damn. Hi. So, is this
this
I don't Is this supposed to prove by the way? Is this supposed
to prove that you're not a bottom? I don't even I Bro,
these people are like on a different planet. They're like got
a totally different culture. I l I don't understand how they're
communicating.
How is How is clinging on to the back of
That's like you're making yourself small and feminine there.
I'm sorry. That's like total bottom energy. This This statement
is like total bottom energy. It's so insulting you call me a
bottom. Did you see that thing I tweeted that was totally like
bottom coded? Did you see that? Well, now now you sure look stupid,
don't you? No.
Okay. Uh, whatever.
This is embarrassing to admit, and I shouldn't have to admit
this, but a big reason why I so quickly felt that I had to prove
like I wasn't I felt like I had to prove I wasn't a bottom and
in turn a top with a tweet I had made 23 is because the idea
of being a bottom makes me afraid of being taken advantage of
within the context of positions. The reasons are very personal
to me because of my trauma and how I have been treated my entire
life. I feel small and powerless and I struggle to say no in
most situations. It's something I've been more actively doing,
rejecting people outright. I don't need the update. I am so genuinely
afraid of being manipulated into situations without my consent
or being forced. It is a huge fear of mine and has been for years.
It genuinely sucks that I have to explain this. None of you should
have to know this much about me. I wouldn't be surprised if it
makes you feel uncomfortable to read because it should make you
uncomfortable. The fact that I feel like I have to explain this
to show the gravity of the situation and why this should never
happen to me.
Okay. I'm trying to I'm trying to maximize charity for like this
kind of position. Okay. I'm trying to like maximize my understanding.
I'm trying to understand it and feel like if I'm trying to if
I'm trying to make sure that this person isn't being dismissed
for no reason,
they might have made it clear that like, hey, I've got trauma
with like being manipulated and when you talk to me this way
or when you when you treat me like what I say to you doesn't
matter. that makes me feel like I don't matter and it like hurts
and you keep doing it and I feel like I have to explain where
all this stuff comes from and the fact that I've explained it
to you for everybody else to understand. So, it's [__]
up that I've shared this with you and now you understand it right
now. You you understand it, but you're making me because you
But then to me,
like I do you want like a full accounting of those things when
he makes his statement and decides to walk away? Cuz it sounds
like he says, "I to people, I hurt people. I'm leaving. I'm getting
therapy. I can't be I can't be around these people anymore. I
I take advantage of people." It seems like that's all inherent
in the things he's saying, right? And I wouldn't have expected
him to be like, "You don't even want to explain it." So, how
was he supposed to explain how he hurt you if you don't want
to explain like right you're you're saying, "Oh, it's up that
I had to explain this." Well, how is he supposed to explain how
he hurt you if that's what you're saying?
Like, you wanted him to do a message outside of the one he did
already. Although, I guess some of this is written before he
released that. The message we read was from November 20th. And
then this is released on well quite recently, but it was written
on the 6th. So, maybe that's more where this is.
Okay. Uh, genuinely sucks. I have to explain this. This that
tweet was made in a moment of comfortability with my a moment
where for once in my life I felt I felt I was okay or I felt
okay with the idea of doing something with someone in person
intimately and Shay ripped this comfort away from me and I have
no reason to share this sort of thing with any and I mean any
and all of you ever again. Back to the timeline of events. The
time is 9:08 p.m. I took the screen cap to the DMs with Shay
to show them proof. Funny how this is the third time we're doing
the proof bit, huh? because I trusted them. They responded.
So they responded shily and teasingly with hey, which I is a
signature for them when they're simp in trying to imply something
involving them. 24.
Oh. Oh, I see. 24. This is what we're reading here. He thinks
like, oh, you're referencing me.
I instantly knew what they meant by this, but hoped I was just
making things up. I didn't want to assume Sheay wanted me to
give them a hickey. It made me revolt at the thought. It disgusted
me. I don't want interactions with Sheay. Why would they say
that? Maybe I'm just overthinking it.
Oh, that's weird. Did you not just want to say it? So, I just
took it as a joke. I teased them. I called them a slur when that
we all reclaimed teasing Lee in this group of friends. Huh? Fler
slur drop. Hold on. Playing the brain worms not to say hi
Waggy. That's a quote, by the way. I dis I disavow slurs. Hi,
Wag. Quote quote unquote hi Waggy in response to your silly ass.
Knowing you, you'd probably like to be called that now. I think
now that I think about it. Yeah.
Read you like a book.
I mean, this is flirting. I'm sorry if you think you're not engaging
in flirting. You're not like,
this is about somebody who's like getting burned by a fire and
they're continuously stoking the fire and feeding more wood to
it, more wood into it, and then they're complaining about being
burned. They're sitting in the fire. All right. And they're adding
more wood to it, throwing gas onto it, and then going, "Guys,
I'm getting burned." Like, "No [__] you're getting
burned. No sh You're getting burned."
Okay, hold on. We're continuing
back to the time we were right here. I joked that they probably
liked it knowing them because I had seen their reaction to being
called that before. They seemingly responded seriously, worsening
the feeling. But I kept it light and playful as much as I could.
We spoke for a couple more messages before the conversation dropped
off at 9:56 p.m. Shay messages me again at
uh midnight 30, so 12:30 a.m. responding to what I said hours
prior, randomly to elaborate and share a photo of themselves
alongside it.
So, the conversation reignites. I call them pretty. They respond
positively using the blushing emoji they use constantly. I send
a padding gift and we regularly exchange for platonic nice reasons.
This is something I usually did with emojis, but did it with
gifts. This was normal. Then Shay responds, "Please."
27.
These are the tweets right here.
Yeah, I'm a bit silly.
Did you Did you really uh read you like a book? Did you really
expect different from an MB who dresses like this?
Pretty goober. Yeah. Okay.
Uh then there's some gift of head pats, please. Dot dot dot.
More heads. You stopping wet cat. Okay. Okay. Like I'm sorry.
You are flirting back. You are just flirting back straight up.
There's actually nothing else we could possibly read into this.
What the
Yeah, gross for one thing, but why the are you pretending that
you're not just explicitly flirting back? You're like, "Oh, I'm
so I'm so right now." Like POV, you're being like
abused by somebody and you keep sending headpack gifts and like
playing into it entirely. Why? Why are you pretending you're
not playing into it entirely? You are.
I'm sorry. You just are. She's pretending this is like without
consent. This is like against her will.
I'm sorry. You can't repeatedly and over just over and over and
over again say well even though it appears like I'm
even though it appears that I'm saying yes and I'm enjoying this
interaction and everything here is positive. Even though it appears
that way there's actually an insidious undercurrent that they
could never possibly understand that is going on here where I'm
like being totally there's actually something in private happening
here that they understand. They're just like me right
I there have to be better examples than this. If this is like
if this is even close to the best example, I'm sorry. This guy
I don't understand why this guy must have this guy must be a
serial killer or something. There's like some reason he would
walk away that he would like confess to everything and just walk
away blanket.
Uh if these are if this is like the best the allegations get,
if this is the worst it gets,
like he didn't I'm not saying he has to come back and like fight
and say these people are lying, but he could just go like that's
not my my impression. I respect these people. It's not my impression
or how it went and I'm gonna I'm gonna take some time, but I'll
be back. He could easily do something like that, but he was just
like, "No, I totally I [__] over everybody who I
ever cared about. I'm a complete monster. I'm retiring. I'm getting
So, when am I getting this though?
Smiley face. Tongue hanging out face.
I'm sorry. You stopping wet cat. That's you fully engaging. That's
escalation on your part.
That's He says, "Please dot dot dot." And you give him another
head pad thing. And then you say you sping wet cat. That's you
escalating.
Clearly that's you escalating. I sent another patting gift called
calling and called them a sping wet cat. An affectionate term
I used to describe characters like character or I don't know
anyone that gives that energy. I was keeping it light like it
should have been. I'm sorry. Everybody else in the world takes
that as like a escalation like you're you're making it.
at 0:39 a.m. Three whole hours after I sent this that screen
cap, Shay responds to it with, "So, when am I getting this
I have to make this text big so it so I can get it through."
Everyone's heads. What was actually said? She for whatever reason
continues to say this was a god eye situation. God situation.
God eye. Dude, why do they keep referencing that's not here?
If you check the videos that should have been posted the other
night, you can see for yourself that the attachment links to
the hickey tweet. If they weren't posted, I will make sure they
are actually posted this time like I wanted originally. I'm saying
this now so I don't forget later, but Jay has actively lied about
the situation to make people to people before making any of the
accountability posts. 29.
Basically, everyone I've spoken to about it agrees it was really
wild. Was literally like a god, I wish that was me joke. But
apparently, it had them fall down a rabbit hole of trauma stuff,
which I do feel really badly about. I just think pinning it on
me was really unfair for one outof line joke. But yeah, that's
why they left. We talked about it a few weeks ago and got some
closure on it, but things are just quiet at the moment. Neither
of us really want to talk about it. Just blleh. I think this
is a totally This is totally reasonable. This completely and
entirely
he says he feels bad. I would say he probably wouldn't want this
shown to the other person cuz he doesn't want to invalidate their
feelings and like make their trauma seem small. But like there's
only so much he could do. Also, I don't believe that he doesn't
think he's escalating in some way there. I think that's a total
lie.
Yeah. When am I getting this though?
He's like flirting. It's just flirting back and forth. Anyway,
uh they were callous in how they talked about it like it was
cloutable. Luckily, the person this was sent to knew better than
to trust what Sheay was saying. No, I I think I just read all
the messages. That seems accurate to me. That seems totally accurate
to me. He can feel, you guys can both have different feelings,
right?
You just have to acknowledge that both of you have different
feelings on it. He is saying, "Listen, I feel bad that there
was something I didn't know about that happened when I made that
when I flirted back that way.
And it makes me it makes me feel bad, but I don't think it's
fair to say that it's my fault that that happened. Even if I'm
the cause, right? There's only there's only so so much I can
do if the thing you're saying I caused like I had no way of being
aware of.
It just seems pretty obvious. I just I and I don't even think
he
he doesn't like misrepresent. It
was literally like a god I wish that was me joke. It's not really
a joke. Maybe this is the misrepresentation that's making her
upset. I think they were flirting and he kept flirting.
I don't know. Okay. Uh but who knows who else who else they said
this to behind closed doors. The implication is that they told
multiple people based on them saying basically everyone I've
spoken to. The most recent accountability post also lied about
it too. Why are you incapable of speaking the truth to directly
quote it was pretty explicitly written as a god I need this.
Was it really now? I don't know. It seems to me like you were
expecting me to give you a hickey. I thought that was a joke.
That part is like oh that's me. That was a joke right? Oh yeah.
No. Hold on. God I need this. The joke. Yeah, that's the joke.
Sorry, with the hickey part. That's definitely a joke. Right.
Hold on. Go back up to this. Hey, he's like, "Oh, I'm I'm a fanboy
who wants a hickey.
That's like a That's a joke. That is a That is a joke." And also,
it's like a Darius joke, right? It's like a 50/50. It's like
a hey, if you if you like this, then we could go down this route,
but if you don't, that's fine. Like plausible deniability.
He's doing the Darius thing, but it's like in a way that's easily
deniable. Easily he could be put off. I don't know. It seems
like you were expecting me to give you a hickey. Funny joke you
got there. I laughed so hard. Honestly, it sounds more like a
demand to me than a joke. It's It's not. It's definitely not.
This is definitely way overblown. I was confused. Horrified.
Oh, hold on. Sorry I'm getting carried away and speaking directly
to Shay instead of all of you. My apologies. Shut. Oh my god.
It's the only way I can express this now without speaking to
them directly. I don't really want to do that after the last
two convers confrontations we had. I'll speak on that later.
So, apparently there are accountability posts from his Discord
that I'm going to need to get to eventually. I wonder if they're
in the document cuz we definitely need those accountability posts.
We're going to need them. They need to be here. So, let's see.
Oh, I was confused, horrified. She had just confirmed the concern
I had that I assumed was just me overthinking. I assumed I just
misunderstood. So, I asked for clarification on if they were
talking about me or in general. 30. Did we miss one of these?
Okay. For from me or you mean in general? Either sounds pretty
good to be honest. So, this is going back to the hickey thing.
That's very cute, but you know, I meant that tweet in a context
and not a platonic one, right? You dork. Oh, well, I mean, those
two aren't terribly distant from me, so I'll have to decline
on the hickey, but I can give you an awesome hug and head paths.
I'll happily accept those. Actually, not into hickeys at all,
so Laauo, I might be a bit of a goober.
Oh, yeah. Actually, it was a joke. It totally was. I totally
wasn't making a pass. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Uh, this guy I'm certainly starting to get a read that this guy
wants he wants totally conflict and like risk-free interactions
with people. He doesn't want to put himself out there at all.
And so he's constantly I think there's something going on here.
Bub Rob, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
Www.
Thank you. I'm probably going to keep reading this. I kind of
I took I took like a bunch of caffeine. I'm not going to sleep
anytime soon, so I'm probably just going to keep reading this.
Thank you for the donation. Appreciate it,
I think what I'm starting to get as a read is this guy might
be one of those people who mixes in who tries to make sure all
of their stuff is explicable through something else. So all their
escalations any any indication there is being coded so that they
can off they can play it off as probably because they've got
a bunch of ace friends right and they are used to going and being
then feeling rejected and having to cover it up.
So I think he's like he mixes these things together. So, I can
see why these people are confused, but it's like cowardice on
his part. He just doesn't want to put himself out there. He should
just be like, "Hey, I think you're hot. Do you want to [__]
Do you want to like say like it should be something almost like
that?" Yeah. It should be like more upfront. It shouldn't be
the like, "Oh, I'm going to develop a friendship with you for
a long period and then, oh, now I want to [__] you."
Uh, also, we do platonic kissing and platonic heads and platonic
like laying in each other's laps and plonic platonic cuddling,
platonic showering together and platonic everything. No, you
don't. You can't just call platonic.
Can't platonically have I'm sorry that doesn't
Can't take all the Wouldn't you guys I know you're ace, but wouldn't
it be cool if you'd like platonically suck my dick? It's just
like an act of service. It's just really like it would be a really
nice thing for you to do if you just platonically suck my dick.
Don't make it. Okay. Can you just platonically blow
I need you to platonically suck my balls, please, right now.
Could you platonically suck my balls? Okay.
Shay doubled down twice
from the the joke was aimed at me. It was sounded pretty good
to be given a hickey for me. The arrow ace who had never had
never done anything intimate with anyone who had never given
a hickey. I've never even kissed someone with romantic or intent.
So, I clarified again thinking maybe they didn't realize I was
being serious or that it was a threat. Okay, it's going down
to 30.
Oh, you didn't really clarify.
Yeah, you said you meant the tweet in a context, not a platonic
one.
So, this is the weird This is the weird [__] that
they do. A lot of these people She's going to say that like,
"Oh, I can talk to on Twitter, but like with friends and stuff,
I could never talk like I'd never actually have a relationship,
but I tweet several things on Twitter,
which is just crazy. I'm sorry. That's like a very weird It's
just a very weird position to have." Okay,
that's And then I expect you to know the difference. Shay doubled
down twice, took none of the opportunities to shut down the joke
they made.
Platonic interactions aren't terribly different to Shay. It made
me rethink every single interaction we had once months had passed.
How much of what we said, what we did was being taken. If platonic
aren't distant, that what was our platonic friendship? I declined.
31. It hadn't sunk in yet just how bad it was. Just like New
Year's of 2023, I was ready to sweep this under the rug and take
it to the grave with me. I felt the horror yet chose to ignore
it because Sheay wouldn't actually do this to me, right? Or do
that to me, right? I think they realized their up telling me
that they weren't into hickeys anyway. Sure. I'm glad this was
funny for you. I sent a headpad gift, unsure of how to deal with
I I followed up with the same thing I was doing already. She
continued speaking, speaking, and speaking, saying they wanted
headpads for real. I admitted to them finally it was jarring
to hear what they said. They apologized instantly, telling me
they didn't mean it, conveniently acting like they were unsure
if I was Arow ace. What is arrow ace now? I get what I get what
a but what is the arrow arrow ace? What is this?
So for individuals who are both a-romantic
and this is weird cope. This is weirdly really really weird cope.
I'm sorry. These people say they're a-romantic and a and then
they have nothing but thoughts and and like bordering on sex
conversations.
Like you're not fooling anybody. What what are you doing? No
no no. But they they constantly have things that are like that
they would get from romantic relationships. They're like, "Oh,
we're going to figure out a way to put a friend label on this.
Is this like a a a fear of taking risks, a fear of like being
rejected? What is this?"
It's just a it's a weird cope that you have going on where you
offload all of your thoughts onto Twitter. You offload all of
your like romantic thoughts and feelings into friendly conversations
that you call platonic but aren't platonic and nobody else would
read as
What is What are you doing? Why? What is this whole thing?
Okay, we're over to 32.
Uh, that's very cute. But you know what I meant? I meant that
tweet in a context, not a platonic one, right? Yeah. Sometimes
I forgot other people think differently about that stuff than
I do. Lauo, for me, stuff can be platonic. I don't view them
as different things. Just up to the people involved. Need this
for real, though. Also, hope you're doing well.
Uh, I think establishing this before saying something like that
is important because I can't lie, having you say something like
that to me was quite jarring. So, I understand that this is how
they feel. So, this is their whole going to be their whole thing
around trauma that I think a partner, an ex-boyfriend had made
like their the ex-boyfriend had made their kink into something
that was like normal in their relationship and she didn't realize
it was a kink until like later and she feels like she has trauma
around that. It's a claim.
Oh, sorry. I was mostly just kidding. Don't worry. Was not serious.
I know you're a ace too, I think. Sorry if that made you feel
weird. I apologize. You're good. You've explained a lot in the
past that you like being flirty and that you do this with your
friends. Just be careful. Yeah, I'm not really the best person
to be including things into platonic flirting and that isn't
your fault cuz you didn't know. Maybe I should have said something
way before. And I think to check with the person and be direct
is important cuz that was a bit of a jump scare. Too real feeling.
Sorry again. It was mostly a joke. I understand though. Uh, it
is so interesting to me that back when I told them I knew information
about their situation with another friend, they said to me being
arrow is a reason why it might be uncomfortable for me to learn
about their dynamic. So why is there such A HESITANCE NOW? OH,
HOLD ON. Did she just cook? Did this arrow ace person just cook?
He did reference that earlier. He was like, "Hey, you guys, I
feel bad that you had to hear somebody tell you about like my
uh my thing cuz your arrow aches." You're like, "You don't like
that kind of stuff." I think that did happen.
Wait, I think she kind of cooked actually. Hold on. Which picture
was it? Hold on. This person gave me screenshot. I'm trying to
phrase it explicitly.
Uh, this is the conversation. Sorry, I got a little anxious earlier
because of your tweet. This is Oh, wait. Hold on. This is 2025,
though.
We'll have to see the timeline. I don't see the arrow ace thing
here. I don't see the ace thing. I don't see the aromantic thing.
Am I missing it? [__] Looking looking. I don't see
it. Hold on. 2023. Okay.
Nope. I need to
I it don't know. That would be interesting though if he was basically
saying like
if he was basically saying something along the lines of like
I'm sorry that somebody revealed something weird about me to
you especially cuz you're arrows. You're like you're a-romantic
as and then he's later going wait I you didn't want me to say
that I see platonic and relationships as very similar. Oh that
makes you feel weird. Oh yeah that makes sense cuz you're arrows.
Like I there might be something there that could be interesting.
Go back to this.
Um for two reasons. One, that's extremely private. And two, it
would probably Oh, very comfortable you're here. I know you're
ace and you don't like that stuff. Lol. Oh, there you go.
Yeah, this is almost a year later.
Ah.
I I know that you have like these proclivities. I know that you're
neurode divergent in this way. When it comes to like people hearing
when you hearing bad when it comes to you hearing bad things
about me, but when I'm saying things to you, when I'm trying
to get with you, when I'm trying to escalate in some way, I totally
forget ABOUT THIS THING. OH,
THIS IS THE first this is the first thing I've seen that actually
makes me go, "Oh, wait. This person might have some problems.
Oh, wait. This person might actually like kind of disregard boundaries."
Interesting. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. I see. I see. So why is there such hesitance now?
Is it because they potentially saw me expressing that I was unsure
if I was Aerowas once in the vent channel because I was trying
to figure out what was going on with my That's speculation on
my part, but that if that's the case, then why the actual would
you take advantage of that? Every outcome in my opinion as to
why Shay would do this all lead to Shay not acting appropriately.
They pushed against a they pushed against a boundary, pushed
the limits of our friendship, and tested the waters to see if
something stuck. Don't pull this with anyone again who you know
is Arows. Don't pull the demanding joke with anyone. I mean,
he wasn't demanding. He literally wasn't demanding. He wasn't.
That wasn't
It's creepy and weird. It borders on harassment. I'm guessing
if you're tweeting several things, he could have easily forgotten
in the moment. He could have easily thought, "Oh, this isn't
a thing. She's changed." I don't know. For this guy, he should
probably stop hanging around with people who are a-romantic.
One, because that seems like a total mental illness designation,
but
because because
he wants to [__] people. If you want to [__]
people, don't hang out with people who explicitly don't want
to. It's like all of the people you hang out with.
What are you doing?
Jay said this was mostly a joke and I told them not to worry.
I feel bad for saying this as it took me time. It took time for
me to wake up that this wasn't okay whatsoever. I pushed down
my feelings to make them feel better about it. Then they told
me, anonymous one, I would never ever ever do anything that would
make you feel uncomfortable. I know what they meant by this really.
They meant to say they would never intend to make me uncomfortable.
The cruel irony is this was the most uncomfortable I had been
I had felt about talking to Shay since New Year's of 2023.
Um, this can be uncomfortable for people or this can be bad for
people if you tell them like if you tell them I'd never do this
to you. If you if you make somebody uncomfortable and then you
tell them I' I'd never make you uncomfortable.
If you don't say explicitly, so I I see why she's like communicating
this. If you don't say explicitly, um
I'd never try to do that. Like it
um that can be bad. Sometimes it it doesn't matter, but
I can see why he just made her feel uncomfortable. Seems like
something.
Okay. Uh I just chocked it up to an autism slip up. We all have
them. completely miscommunicating the situation entirely. It
was a one no second a one no second big time mistake they had
made. This wasn't something other people went through. Right.
I don't see either of these things as huge. I this whole first
person.
If this is the person that caused like a landslide on this, it
would be funny if he wasn't if he was like guilty of a bunch
of stuff because this is a total false positive for me. Like
essentially everything discussed in this in this tweet longer,
this person's specifically, this all feels like not relevant.
Not even not anything to me.
Anyway, we continue going on. Where are we here? Okay. All right.
Proditional context since it sounds weird without this. I'm diagnosed.
Saying they had an autism slip up isn't a slight. It's how Shape
portrayed it to me themsel whenever explaining their actions
to me. They regularly used missing cues and autism as an explanation
for their actions. I see. How did I find out other people went
through this too? I hope you don't mind when that I start this
with some of our interactions for context. Our last interactions
for context. I kept all this to myself for months, acting like
things were normal. I actually kind of forgot it had happened
at a lot of points because of how far down I buried it. I had
started to distance myself from trusted chat and had been hanging
out with people in smaller groups due to the nature and vulgarity
that I was sick of get that I was getting sick of. I'm sorry.
I stopped instigating conversations with Shay as much and kind
uh as much kind of subconsciously. I was supportive and they
supported me. They were still the there were still the odd interactions
that were more personal like venting to each other or congratulating
them on runs. GDQ came Oh, right. They're all speedr runners.
Huh. A lot going on there. GDQ came around and we were still
friendly and supportive with each other. I had ended up venting
to Shay eventually about my feelings about trusted. I didn't
feel like I belonged. I blame myself for not enjoying the conversations
of vulgarity. I was also having family issues around that time.
So, I was extremely broken up. This was the last conversation
that me and Shay had that felt meaningful and personal where
I felt comfortable to vent to them. Took place on the 28th of
July,
36. I don't know why we missed 35. Oh, this is the autism stuff.
Autism jokes. So, this is
2 months later.
Okay. I wish I could truly believe that, but I just feel like
nothing is enough to convince my brain that. Especially when
barely anything I say is ever of interest. It feels like whenever
I am myself around other people.
Uh, barely anything I say is ever of interest. It feels like
whenever I am myself around other people.
Uh, I just don't feel like I fit in anywhere. I'm not vulgar
enough. I don't think about romance enough. I don't enjoy other
people's interests enough. I'm not smart enough. I'm not I'm
too opinionated. And I'm too sensitive at the same time. You
don't need any of those things to fit in. You fit in just by
being you. by being awesome. And you're not smart enough. You're
one of the smartest people I know. I appreciate your sensitivity.
I trust you more than anybody else in my life. I feel incredibly
comfortable talking to you about anything because I know you
have the sensitivity and touch to talk to me as well. Okay. Wow.
On August 1st, 2025, me and Shay had a conversation about their
trip to Cedar Point. It was short, but ended with Shay saying,
"I would like I look like I would be extremely comfortable to
cuddle with before telling me after I had hoped we could meet
again or meet someday. Absolutely, me too." 10 minutes later,
they followed it up with, "Definitely going to make it happen.
You're like one of my closest friends. I want to visit one day."
Okay, such a dork. Takes one to no one,
Bestie, I got to say, you look like you'd be extremely comfortable
to cuddle with. Friendshaped. I could do cuddles and hugs right
now. It's been so long since I've hung out with a buddy. One
year to be almost exact. I hope we can hug someday. Absolutely.
Me, too. Definitely got to make that happen. You're like one
of my closest friends. I want to visit one day.
Okay, dude. I'm just thinking of that one guy who's doing like
the Ocarina of Time speedrun and then the people want some woman
wants to do like a public service announcement during it and
he's just like focused up trying to get his Ocarina speedrun
done. Anybody got that video? I You guys know what I'm talking
about, right? I feel like I wonder if there's any crossover between
these two communities. If that was like the Undertale speedrunning
community who happened to be sitting there watching or some [__]
additionally on August 15th. So, this didn't seem bad. I don't
even know what this was. Like you could say, I guess you could
say that maybe you feel like you this, but this was after he
told you that the platonic and things were kind of close.
Seems like probably that's not somebody you can even talk to
reasonably, right? Oh, did I just do this? Here we go.
Sorry, I I zoomed away from where we
right here. Initially, on August 15th, my birthday, she would
repeat the same sentiment. just to me it was more sinister in
my opinion. They said, "One day when I'm a YouTube millionaire,
I'll fly you out here and we can have a proper party." I reacted
positively and I probably shouldn't have. Then again, at the
at the time, I saw it as being pretty innocent, all things considered.
Okay. I mean,
I'm sorry your birthday isn't a happy time. It should be a time
to celebrate, and I'm sorry it's hard for you. One day when I'm
a YouTube billionaire, I'll fly you out and we can have a proper
party. Yeah, that'd be great. Someday, for sure. Bro, what? This
is not dude. What?
How? You have more viewers than low tier god. Yeah, I'm making
fun of trans people. Get low tier god talking about trans people
and he have like a thousand viewers right now. Okay, get him.
Get him yapping about [__]
Uh, sorry that's a slur. My bad. Listen, I watched that Chud
clip. It's catching on. Okay, just my bad. On the 15th of August,
my birthday. You repeat this. I reacted positively. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. This spooks me now knowing that what went on with some
of their friends that they saw in person. This included but is
not limited to Shay groping Audrey's
This is who he asked at SGDQ 2024.
Azura F. We didn't read this person's thing yet. And cuddling
anonymous three to the point where they could feel Sha's on the
leg on his leg at AGDQ 2025.
Both of them have given me permission to mention these encounters
by name.
here. The conversation dropped off at 9:24 a.m. and Sheay messaged
me again saying someday and then for sure and at 5:46 p.m. as
you can see 8 hours after the conversation had been dropped.
However, before my birthday, I had begun to discuss my feelings
of Shay exhibiting weird behavior. This was because someone I
was talking to in voice called vague in a voice call vaguely
brought up something related to how Sha's behavior reflected
untrusted chats vulgarity and nature. It woke me up completely
and a place for me to talk about everything was made for me.
I finally told a small set a set a set small group of people
my exact two main experiences with Shay up to that point in the
early hours of the 9th of August 2025. Told them everything sobbing
as I did it. Years of anxiety I couldn't pinpoint the reason
for finally connecting together to form what it is now. Why was
I so nervous and antsy whenever I got a DM from Shay? I had just
thought I was completely parasocial. No, subconsciously I've
been pushing down discomfort from both of the two big interactions
that bothered me and a smaller and a the smaller, more subtle
ones that came in between.
No, this person, this is a total smoke screen. This person shouldn't
have actually spoken up. This is [__] crazy. Oh,
I dude the highlighted messages just have a timer for me. Like
I click on it and then I don't do anything else. I don't make
it go away usually. They just have like a highlighted timer.
One of the people contained in this group
uh had had also been personally affected by Sha's/intimate
nature. Anonymous number seven. We both exchanged our stories
to each other and wondered if anyone had been through similar
praying that nobody had. We knew if this became about more than
two people, we would have an issue to deal with. We we assumed
it was just us and waited. We were wrong. Slowly but surely,
as days, weeks, and months passed, I learned of more and more
people who had been through the same or similar interactions
with Sheay through telling them about what happened to me up
until today. There are things that transpired because of this,
but I will touch on them later in chronologically. As a result
of me being so open behind the scenes, slowly learning to trust
other people and them putting their trust in me. We all started
to notice a very prevalent pattern. We were being too playfully
flirted with advances made on us. Facts exchanged which was were
mostly instigated by Shay. Some of us, some were young but of
age when it happened. The majority of us are feminine often Aphab
assigned female at birth.
Some of us are vulnerable and not appropriate to be initiating
flirtatious conversation/ acts with. Again, I'm arrows. I was
unavailable. Eventually, I've decided I needed to take action
or I had decided the first confrontation
on August 22nd, 2025.
I sent my very first and what I intended to be. Should I get
some goofy music going? Dude, what the is happening?
This is the This is the music. Oh, that's my docket. This is
the music that's
Best of Christian Loi chill instrumental worship. And then it's
this picture of like I assume Daniel in the lions
in the lion den in the lion's pit. And they're like all Mustafa.
Mustafa. Mufasa. Why did I say Mustafa? Mufasa. Jesus Christ.
I What the It's like this is such a weird thing for my playlist
to go to automatically. I It's bizarre. Yms. No, there's no scars
there. There's no scars. Yms is fine. This is not a YMS thing.
It's not like that.
I was just going to go put up the um what do you call it? The
My Hero Academia music. Just seems to be appropriate for this
kind of thing. Although, actually, Full of Hell sent me a playlist,
too. Give me a second.
Is this appropriately
depressing, distressing music? I think he said it was a goth
playlist. Okay, I see. I I feel like I understand. I need to
turn this down a little bit, but Okay. Okay, hold on. You get
the volume just right. That might be good. Okay,
this is the first
the first confrontation as I explained in this message. Okay,
we have to go read it the whole thing.
Hello. I'm sorry that what I'm about to say is really out of
the blue. I wish I could feel comfortable enough to have a real
discussion about how I'm feeling right now. To be honest, I don't
think I can do that. I am genuinely so sorry. It hurts me a lot
to do this and I know it will hurt you, but I do this with the
intent of having peace of mind and looking out for myself. I
really struggle to set boundaries, so I hope you can understand
why I'm having a hard time with it. For for a while, and especially
more recently, I've been coming to terms with a lot of personal
feelings regarding or intimate situations. I've experienced a
lot of misgivings when it comes to these things in my life, and
it hurts to say that there's been a couple of interactions we've
had in the past that made me feel uncomfortable. I know your
intentions. Your intention isn't malicious or to do this on purpose
and I know how passive I tend to be. However, you know I'm arrows
and I think regardless of your intent, your actions have caused
me distress and confusion in a few instances. It's something
that is regularly on my mind no matter how much time passes or
how resolved it feels in the moment.
Deep down, I know these things shouldn't have been said to me
in the first place, especially considering my aversion to interactions,
which is why my intense discomfort continues today. I don't feel
comfortable having an open conversation about this. Like I uh
like I said already or like I already said, but I will tell you
what you can do to avoid this in the future. I don't want you
to feel like you cannot grow and become a better person from
this, but I believe you can.
Please don't take anything take people saying things in a private
space as an invitation to insert yourself into it without explicit
consent first. I also understand that you like to play/platonically
flirt with your friends, but please consider what you are saying
and how extreme it is before you say it, especially when that
friend of yours has told you they're arrow ace. I don't expect
you to remember my experiences from what I've told people making
unwanted advances onto me or my experiences that I've told with
people making unwanted advances onto me. But you don't know what
sort of impact something like that could have on someone, especially
with how much influence you have over other people. I mean, this
seems really unreasonable again to me. Not that he should do
this, not that it's okay for him to do it, but it seems really
unreasonable to basically when they make some jokes about you,
you go, "Oh, I'm not a bottom. actually I'm a top and you post
a tweet to them and you're like told you I'm a top like it should
just be hey I don't have
I don't have inclinations towards you I don't want to have conversations
that needs to be what it is that needs to be the only answer
right it shouldn't be oh here's a p here's a tweet I made on
my private Twitter about how I like engaging
that shouldn't that's oh you're already participating in something
you should
anyway
it feels weird to do that and then to get mad at this guy for
sort of playing back and feeding off of that energy.
I understand that they're going to say, "Well, I told them I
was arrow ace first." Well, maybe they thought you'd change your
mind. Maybe they thought it wasn't that way. I don't know. Arow
ace, a-romantic
arrow ace. Okay, people may be more hesitant to say no to someone
who they respect and want to make happy, even if it makes them
uncomfortable. I know this from many times I've felt this way
in my whole life. It can feel scary. That's like fine, but you,
God, you have to have some way of communicating that your boundary
is being violated, right? you have to have some way of communicating
to this person.
Um, I would say that if he did this repeatedly, then it would
become bad again, right? That like, hey, this this kind of one-off,
two-off interactions
over years,
maybe I I can probably give him a pass on that. If it was like
consistent, if he was doing it like every other month and there
was like eight examples, I would go, "Oh, yeah. This guy's pretty
this guy's pretty annoying."
cuz we did have the example of him knowing about her boundary
when it was like, "Oh, somebody told me something weird about
you." Or he was he his impression was that then he was like,
"Oh, that's weird. They said something cuz you're arrows. That
would really hurt you."
Anyway,
>> uh, I'm going to be direct about what I am planning
to do to set my boundaries. I'm going to block you after sending
this message so I can have my space. I know this is selfish,
but I simply cannot handle a response or conversation. It will
ruin me. I need my space in peace. Then I will remove you from
my server and my private Twitter as well as unfollowing your
private Twitter so you can have your space too. I will then be
leaving your server and any other servers I feel I should. Anything
else is up to you to decide such as public follows, mutual servers
we're in together. Whatever the case, I would prefer if you not
do not directly contact me until further notice. I hope you can
understand.
Okay, that seems fine. I just can't believe that. Um oh, this
will be his response. Let's see.
So, uh I'm not going to elaborate further on why Oh, hold on.
As I explained in the message and as Shay has mentioned to several
people without my perition, this was awake. This awakening did
also open my eyes to a running history of situations I had faced
in my life that related to situations. Yes, I realized I've trauma.
I'm not going to elaborate further on why um on my why or what
happened in my past that caused me to have this trauma. I've
already said enough and quite frankly, I'm disgusted that Shay
has gone around people telling people that this trauma spiral
I went down or about this trauma spiral I went down, that was
not their place to mention at all. Anyho,
anyhow, after I sent Okay, so I can see I'd say that the reason
this person was upset earlier, I wasn't sure why they were upset
and what they wanted him to say. I think they're pretty upset
that he was talking to them, talking to other people about why
she left and then going like, well, she, you know, she just had
this thing and she doesn't feel like it was represented accurately,
which is like fair. It's probably fair for her to reach out to
those people and correct.
>> We can infer the trauma. Sure. Are you good in further
trauma? Possibly. You don't know exactly what it is, though.
Like, you don't I don't know. You don't even know that it's
I mean, dude, this person's pretty out there. 2940. So, this
is 29 is the old message where
29 was this one.
Uh, basically, everyone I' So, he sent this to somebody else.
Everyone I've spoken to about it agrees with it was really wild.
It was literally like a God, I wish that was me joke, but apparently
it had them fall down a rabbit hole of trauma stuff, which I
do feel really badly about. I just think pinning it on me was
really unfair for one out of line joke. But yeah, that's why
they left. We talked about it a few weeks ago and got some closure
on it, but things are just quiet at the moment. Neither of us
really want to talk about it, so just blleh.
And so
he says,
"I just can't believe that. I'm sorry. I can't believe I'm worth
knowing or being friends with. Not when I keep up and hurting
people. Why do you think blank left weeks ago?" "Because I was
[__] stupid idiot and I made a stupid completely
out of line remark." Because I wanted to be funny. Because I
can't read a goddamn social cue to save a life. And how did that
go for me? I put my friend, someone I deeply care about, I care
about deeply, someone who means so much to me, into a trauma
spiral that deeply wounded them because of something I did. Because
of something I said. I hurt someone I care about so goddamn much
because I'm a dumbass.
Um,
this is true,
They did get hurt.
I'm trying to think of like how you should approach this. I'm
like bad at this stuff.
Like while I think this is true, something about how how much
you could foresee this, how much you could understand it does
play in here. And I think this guy is engaging in like a little
bit too much uh an extreme
like he's got like an extreme
self flagagillation concept or uh complex like he's he's self
flagagillating a lot. Yeah.
Like I I just don't think this is reasonable to think of it this
way that like you you [__] up so deeply.
this is him referencing it to somebody else. He's talking about
it to someone else. I'm going to say this in the messages, right?
Anyhow, after I sent this message, I blocked Shay like I had
warned them at the time. I simply did not want to deal with the
stress and anxiety of having to respond to their immediate reaction.
I'd already been through enough of that even typing the message
up and the last several weeks had been a never- ending hell to
begin with. This boundary wouldn't last, though. On August 27th,
2025, I unblocked a message to express my distaste with the fact
that profile picture they were using was a complete redraw of
my Halloween witch art I had personally made for them at my request.
The same art from 2024. Now, I have my own feelings about the
communication between Sheay and me relating to permission being
given to literally redraw my heart almost exactly, but it's not
something you should care about particularly. I'm just outlining
the reason communication started back up again. She apologized,
so it's whatever. After this short conversation, she asked if
we could talk. I told them I didn't want to. I'd already stated
to them I wasn't ready to unblock but to go on ahead.
41.
Can we please talk? I don't want to, but if it's something you
want to do whilst I have you unblock, then go ahead. Hurt me
so incredibly badly. You didn't even give me a chance to at least
explain anything or even to just have any kind of weight on saying
bye or anything like that. I understand what you told me. I went
back and read through the interactions in question. I'm sorry
I did not pick up on the social cues. I wish, dude, the social
cues were like non-existent. There weren't there were not social
cues there. It was like,
bro, there there were not social cues you could pick up on. This
is not autism that he's missing these signals because of. In
fact, I feel like he's confessing and that shows that he might
actually be a He's like he's like telling her he missed the social
cues that don't exist there,
right? Like there essentially are no social cues at all whatsoever.
And he's going I missed the social cues and I I couldn't pick
up on it. I'm sorry.
No social cues equals no. Wait, what do you think he asked for?
Oh, Nate dot, you just said you just said you didn't actually
watch the whole thing. You didn't understand. Why don't you go
watch? Why don't you go back in in the video and watch or wait
for the video? Either one. I'm telling you that he was basically
like the thing she didn't want him to do was say, "Oh, that that
tweet you did. I actually wish you'd do that to me."
That it's like
that sounds way worse than what it even is. It was like about
giving a hickey.
Uh anyway,
um
see here. I wish I was able easily able to, but it's something
I immediately apologized for and never repeated. And while that
doesn't take at all take away from how you felt uncomfortable,
it still hurt me so so badly when you fully cut me off and didn't
let me say didn't even let me say anything. I feel like after
all we had done, all we had been through, and how close we were,
I at least deserve that. I said it before, but I'll be crystal
clear. I am extremely sorry a stupid joke attempt at a stupid
attempt at a joke made you that uncomfortable. That was never
ever the intention. I was just trying to be funny or lighten
the mood a bit and I completely missed the cue. No, you definitely
kind of thought maybe she's not ace and maybe I've gotten in
here. That's 100% what you thought. Why are you lying? These
things are incredibly difficult for me already and I was pretty
sure you're aware that I struggle with it. But it hurt me incredibly
to just have that suddenly thrust upon me, especially so late
at night, 4:30 a.m. my time, after an already very difficult
day in which I had dealt with a panic attack and was unable to
do anything. It hurts me that I didn't get to say anything back,
to respond, to do anything, even just saying bye. I thought I
would have at least earned that as a friend. So, this is interesting.
this is not always the best thing to do.
listen, it's not bad that you're like this, but me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me. And like I'm sorry that I did this, but
me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me and I know that I did this
but me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me like that's
sort of how
that's sort of how this is going, right? There's like a pattern
that's going on here. Say anything back. I have barely slept
the past few days. I've been stricken with grief grief and self-lo
self-loathing.
It has been absolutely miserable and I just wish you had given
me the basic decency to talk to me at the very least. Of course,
I care about how you feel. I wouldn't like complete and total
dog I wouldn't feel like complete and total dog [__]
over having upset you like this if I didn't care. That hurts
me deeply to know that as a result of something I did, it hurt
someone I care about a lot. Okay. Oh, they continue the conversation.
This is a lot, man. How How are we doing on pages? We got a lot
of pages left. Jesus Christ. By the way, I just want to make
it clear that this is her written statement
for her one allegation. After this, I don't know if you can see
this in the top left here. Let me show you in the top left. Okay,
so we're on written statement. There's her screen caps, collections
of patterns, and blah blah blah. Second messages, blah blah blah.
Shay's second accountability post. And then we've got Azura F,
Anonymous 3, Willie, Willy J, Willy J, Say, Jade's Evolution,
Prisma, Ray, Xander, Yellow, Anonymous 2, Anonymous 4, Anonymous
5, Anonymous 6, Anonymous 7, Anonymous 8, Anonymous 9, anomous
10, anonymous 11. So, like in terms of having this finished,
I think we are like 5% in.
We're like 5% in. I think I'm guessing some of these other accounts
are like a paragraph or two.
Jesus. I can grab some food. Holy [__]
I don't know if I can do the whole thing, man.
>> I'm going to try to, but I'm like hungry. I need more
caffeine. [__] me.
What's up, Pork Chops TV?
>> Give me a second. I'm gonna get some food and some caffeine.
Well, I I have food, but I'm grab another slice of pizza. Right
back.
Okay, we're back.
>> What page are you on? I thought it was like 250 pages.
I am on page 8 of 26. It might be like 250 pages. Oh, but hold
on. I'm way past 8 of 26.
>> Am I missing context? Is the person writing this insane?
I think this person's insane. >> I think some of the other
people are not insane. probably
>> I'm just getting caffeine. One second.
My my mix. Okay, my my G Fuel, but it's not G-Fuel. It's like
something way more
Get like a caffeine mix to
I don't like coffee. So, okay. >> Load it up in the shaker
cup.
I'm just talking to you guys because I'm like literally
something else. I don't want to read while I do this. Okay, so
what was the most recent example? We're way past this. How did
I get so far? Okay, I see.
We're down more. First confrontation. We're down to here. Okay.
Okay. Unblocked. Talked about the art.
Shay guilted me over the fact that I had sent my message and
blocked him telling me about how awful it was for them, how they
had a difficult day, how it was late at night, how I should have
given them the basic decency to let them talk to me. I felt so
guilty, but I pushed through and defended myself. 42. They responded
to use the fact that I know about their trauma against me. It
made me feel like I was wrong for doing any of this despite the
fact that I have every right to. I had to do what I had, what
I did for myself and my own trauma. To move on and heal is what
I needed. and to talk to Shay and be exposed to the full brunt
of their reaction was going to send me over the edge. One of
our comforts had to be sacrificed and I sacrificed mine to Shay
too many times. It had to be done. Okay, that's fine.
>> I understand that. I understand that it was something
I had to consider and wait on me when it came to making the decision
to send that message. To be frank, I don't think I need to explain
the hell I've gone through over the past couple of days because
you already feel bad enough and I don't need to add to that.
But I had every right to do what I did. And even if it hurt,
it was probably the best thing I could have done for both myself
and for you. Even if it doesn't feel like it, I think it would
have gone a lot worse if you didn't have the time to sit and
think about your feelings and what you wanted to say. And the
same goes for me. In that moment and still now, I need time and
space to think about how I feel and how this has affected me
in the back of my mind. I knew someday I'd probably be able to
come back to you and have a discussion, but I wanted to keep
that to myself until I knew I was ready and wanted to do so.
Otherwise, you might have been I'm trying to read faster. You
might have been waiting for something that would never come.
The feelings I have are very personal and deep rooted. They come
from a place of trauma and repeated bad experiences. You of all
people should know how badly that tolls in someone. I need the
space to process that. And I made sure my message to be upfront
and about what I planned to do and how you could do better. I
didn't have to, but I did it because I felt you deserved to know
as my friend. I understand that and you know that much of what
I'm feeling now is also rooted in trauma. You're one of the very
few people I've opened up to and I you know I have severe issues
with lack of agency in situations. Again, I'm sorry I missed
the mark with that joke so badly. I want to be super cris clear,
super crystal clear. I never wanted expected or even ever once
have ever entertained anything regarding pursuing you in any
kind of way like that. I know you've had horrible, terrible experiences
with people doing that to you. I never at any point have ever
thought of you in that way or anything other than just a close
friend. I valued you as that and exclusively as that a close
friend. I know I said the stupid joke. I know it my it may have
come off as attempting to approach. It was not. It never was.
And I'm I feel like he's just lying here. I feel like this is
a little bit gaslighting on his end now to be honest with you,
dude. Yeah. I I don't think so, man. I think this is like totally
Damn, I know that feeling. Cam the jelly man. except the part
about the kid, but
Uh, then you need to rethink how you interact with people regarding
being flirtatious with your jokes or comments because it's getting
to it's going to get you in trouble into trouble if you don't
do anything about it. It's bordering on irresponsible, especially
with the status you have. You can't just be saying this sort
of stuff. I held you as someone I deeply respected and therefore
made exceptions for directly because I saw you so highly. Even
though we were close friends, it was part of why I was so passive
and I tried so hard to avoid confrontation by being blunt and
honest like I would be with anyone else. I held so much respect
for you. I'd hope you wouldn't do that sort of thing to me. You
told me what I said was too far. I apologized and never did it
again. I put significant thought into how I interact with people
and I've been exceptionally careful and wary of people's boundaries
at every step of the way. To be blunt, I was confused in the
moment because I was receiving mixed messages. I thought it was
okay to push a joke in that moment because it felt like we were
just having a light-hearted jokey conversation. There was never
anything further than that and I immediately apologized and backed
off the moment you said something. I do not just go up to people
and I don't know and I I don't just go up to people I don't know
and act that way to them. We've been close friends for years.
I would not be comfortable and would never consider talking like
that to someone I just met. That would be insane. He responds,
I will ask since I have the opportunity to do so then. Why was
this something you went back to hours later as if it was a if
it was just a joke then? What was the intention behind that?
I'm not sure what you're referring to here. Give me a moment
to look. Huh? He did sort of follow up in a way. That's I think
he's like kind of lying here. I think he he's doing the Darius
thing and he can't admit he was doing the Darius thing. And that
that will be bad for somebody with trauma around this stuff.
If you're just going to lie, right, that's going to [__]
them up.
That is that is actually going to [__] them up if
you just say, "No, no, no. I didn't do that. No, no, no. didn't
do what? I would never I would never try flirting with you ever.
I would Oh my god. I would never do that. It's like, bro, you
are flirting. You're not like being inappropriate. And I could
understand why he thought it was like coded in a way that he
could get away with it. And like he's just kind of testing the
waters a little bit. I totally get why all that stuff would happen,
right?
It feels weird that he's just saying, "No, no, no. This wasn't
flirty." Yeah, it was. What are you talking about? You're like,
"Oh, where's my hickey?
You're You're like the creepy uncle. the creepy like old guy.
All right. Oh, where's my hug? Oh, where's my hickey? Where's
my hickey?
Weirdo. Dude, I asked them what their intent was behind this.
Blah blah blah blah. I'm just going to I'm going to honestly
skip their explanation cuz all of the messages just tell us the
whole thing. When I first sent you the tweet, you responded in
a way that implied the joke you made after I caught that much.
That implied the joke you made after. So, it was jarring to see
you Reese did it more openly. When you said this, that was when
it was made clear to me that I had made a mistake and made you
uncomfortable. I did not realize up until that point, I'm sorry,
I'm a and I don't parse things super easily. I need to be told
directly, which you did, and then I backed off. Not a single
conversation later did anything like this happen uh happen again.
And it was it would have continued that way because you established
the boundary. I would have continued to have respected that.
You don't need to keep reiterating that. You would not have continued.
I understand that /gen.
Uh I just want What is/gen? I understand that. Slen,
I just wanted to understand better your intentions and why you
would do it in the first place. And I want you to understand
to the fullest why you shouldn't be acting that way to people
you consider friends.
Unless you have explicit consent beforehand. Joke or not, it
was out of line. Because you were one of my closest friends,
I just thought it was okay because, well, a lot of my friends
make jokes like that. My other close friends crack jokes like
that all the time.
I just wasn't thinking fully in that moment. I thought that a
joke like that would be okay. It wasn't. I made a mistake. I
get it. I know. I'm sorry. I know I made a mistake. I'm sorry.
I just It hurts me a lot that a slip up like this is being magnified
like this and pulled up months after the fact when it should
have been clear from my actions that it was never going to happen
again. I didn't have intentions. I was just trying to be funny.
I don't know what that means in this context.
I just want to better understand your intentions and why you
do it in the first place. Okay. I didn't have intentions. Well,
you had some intention. Everyone has intentions when they say,
"Yeah, your intent was to be
Yeah. Like you're arguing your intent is to be funny. Don't say
you don't have intentions. That's not even coded.
>> Genuine, maybe. Okay. Yeah. Tone indicator. Yeah. Okay.
Tone indicator for genuine. I genuinely feel this.
>> Well, then my intention was to be funny. I guess it's
incredibly difficult for me to parse, especially when, well,
you know, a lot of our friend group, you know how we interact.
You know, everything is chill and all done with consent and respect.
It can be really difficult in an environment like that to gauge
particular things. And I am sorry that I slipped up and said
something that I shouldn't have and made a stupid joke. In my
mind, I thought I'd made jokes like that around you before and
it was fine and funny. Haha. And nor and haha normal. And so
I did it again and that was it. I didn't just randomly out of
the blue decide to pursue you or some [__] like that
I had or some in a way I had never tried before. This is as much
as I recall. I can't speak to anything further as to my mental
state at the time because it was months ago. Especially given
the tweet you sent me. It felt like we had just established the
that oh this is an okay level to joke about. I'll make a similar
caliber of joke.
Yeah. I don't think he was I think he was
giving back the same energy which she was coding. Maybe she's
she doesn't realize that it comes off as flirting. It came off
as her flirting and then he flirted back. Like neither of these
people are they just don't want to take responsibility for the
things they were doing. feels like that's that's how it feels
to me. Like they were flirting and now she sees like him as sort
of bad and she doesn't want to take responsibility for flirting
a little bit in her direct like at him and he doesn't want to
take responsibility for flirting as well. Odd
>> I mistook group level of comfort personal. I'm sorry
but I also think this is extremely understandable thing to do.
And it only dawned on me more recently that you know what maybe
they weren't happy or comfortable with that group level stuff.
That's why you left, right? why I took a break. That's why I
reached out to make sure you knew how I felt uh you knew how
you felt was valid and okay to feel that way. I think this is a
problem within itself to normalize something to that extent
to the extent of assuming consent. Like okay, if he was assuming
consent to shove his fingers inside of you, that would be really
bad. He's assuming consent to like send you pictures of his that
might even be bad. But like he's assuming consent to joke with
you in a way that's not even like grossly
He's assuming consent to say like, "Haha, where's my hickey?"
"Haha, where's my hickey, bro? Bro,
come on. Come on. Platonic hickeys. Let's go."
um I would also really appreciate Oh, hold on. Now it's coming
to an interesting spot.
Oh, man.
Did I read this line? I think this is a problem within itself
to normalize something to the extent of assuming con consent
and everyone being fine with certain things that can make people
uncomfortable. That's how it is in a lot of places and it usually
ends up in a similar point where things like this start to happen.
I would really appreciate if you stopped implying this is some
kind of pattern. This was a one-time mistake that won't happen
Sorry, I have to do the music myself because I don't have my
soundboard again. Okay. I I really don't like that you're suggesting
this might be a pattern. Um
15 different allegations later.
15 different allegations later. I've actually undercut that.
It looks like 18
I really don't like that you're assuming this is a pattern.
This is something I've worked on over the past year. I much more
frequently check in to make sure everything is fine. Even if
something is established, I check in to make sure it's oh still
okay and still comfortable. I think out of your original message,
this part is what hurt me most. This was an isolated thing, a
one-time mistake, something I'm usually actually extremely careful
of uh or about normally, like I put great strides into making
sure I check people's comfort, and it felt like you were talking
to me like I was some kind of abuser. I hope someday you improve
is the kind of thing you put into a cancellation document.
Oh, you don't say. You don't say. That's like the kind of thing
you put into a cancellation document.
I feel like
if I had to guess, I feel like around this time in August,
he's done some that is actually bad to other people. I'm guessing
one or two of these are like actually bad. Like actually quite
bad. Like like repeatedly violating boundaries or something along
those lines. And I feel like he's worried that somehow somebody's
going to connect these things. Now I'm starting to read it in
a little bit. Okay.
And now I'm starting to see it just a tiny bit. A tiny bit. Uh,
dude. I
h I hope you improve someday. It's the kind of thing you put
into a cancellation document. That tore me apart because this
was a one-time thing and a mistake I made one time when I'm usually
insanely careful about this stuff. Is it okay not an okay thing
to wish someone improves in a mistake? You can improve upon making
one mistake. I think it's the phrasing of it. It felt so harsh
and also really really badly hit trauma for me. I don't think
most people say I hope you can improve someday to a friend who
made a onetime slip up. A slip up that caused me a lot of grief.
And I am sorry, endlessly sorry that it it did. I've been incredibly
angry at myself more than you can imagine. So I understand where
this guy is coming from. Okay, I I get it. I get where he's coming
from. But you have to understand the other side of it, too, right?
There are two sides to this. The other person feels like you
hurt them and you don't really care about them. And you're responding
with like, "Yeah, I do. I'm sorry for hurting you, but like here's
how I feel." >> You have to understand how that from the
other person's point of view, they're you're sort of validating
that you don't care about them, that you care about yourself
a lot more than them, right? That's definitely happening here,
>> right? He's saying, "Oh, it feels really unreasonable
that you're doing this.
Why don't you think about me? Which listen, I listen, I'm narcissistic.
I get it. Everything's about me.
But you got to sometimes think about how it makes other people
feel. And I understand that because I had to write and send the
message with the knowledge that would hurt you in the process,
but it had to be done. If I hadn't, we wouldn't have been having
this sort of conversation. You wouldn't have had time to think
about everything. It would have been extremely impulsive and
in the moment. You have had time to reflect and think, and I've
had time to process and compose myself, even if it wasn't enough
time that I had hoped. I understand that and I I agree. It was
good to have time to compose. At the same time, blocking me like
that took my agency away. It made me feel trapped and scared.
It took any terms of conversation completely out of my hands
entirely. I would have accepted it if you told me you needed
time to process time away. I would have been more than happy
to wait because yes, I do understand and agree that those kind
of impulsive, emotional conversations like that do more harm
than good. Trust me, I know.
I mean, she said she don't send her a message until she messages
you back or something. Blocking me. Remove my agency. Honestly,
I feel like
there's like It's funny because for this specific one, I think
I think he's border he's almost entirely above board. There is
like some bad stuff, but he's almost entirely above board. Not
really. Can't be cancelled from this, but it seems like he's
almost more concerned about what he'll say to other people than
he is about anything that's being alleged here, right? He's like,
"Oh, this one is like crazy, but I don't want you talking to
other like why would you talk cancellation documents? Why would
you talk to other people about things I've done? This is really
weird. This is going to a weird place.
I understand that. Oh, no, no, no. Hold on. We're down to the
next one. So, you're She responds, I told you I needed my space
and to not contact me until further notice. That was your indicator.
I think it's crude to elude cruel to elude that you into thinking
a conversation is quicker than it actually would be. Youude
that you are thinking a conversation is quicker than it actually
would be. I don't even know because what if it had taken me months
or years, Shay, this is bigger to me than just one slip up. Yes,
objectively it was a mistake, but it was a mistake that had a
huge impact on me and my comforts. It had made me reevaluate
how I see and interact with several topics. I've made a lot of
realization as to why it hurt me as much as it did. And that
is extremely hard to recognize
and realize there's much bigger problem that has caused me to
feel this way that being me having trauma, it was a slip up.
And I understand that. I won't hold you to uh hold it to you
that you up by making a joke that was out of line.
The impact and how hard it was to me to confront you about this
later. How difficult it has been to accept what you said was
wrong and I need to be away from you to process and to be okay
have uh to have a conversation has been huge. It has taken over
my life for the last week. It has been difficult and not at all
and not all of that is your fault. But yes, the slip up you made
played a huge part in it. I can't even begin to imagine what
this feels like. I'm not going to burden you with what it does
feel like because again, you feel bad enough and it would be
wrong to inflict that onto you with the details.
I mean, I'm sorry. You just can't.
Sorry, you can't.
>> I don't know, man. If she could show me like explanations
beyond the arrowace thing
that like she'd gone through a lot of this trauma with him or
or explained it in a way that he really should understand, maybe
I could maybe I could understand this response. But this guy
thinks that he's going to be able to fix it by taking responsibility
and he's
He's definitely not.
One second. Okay. All right. I understand and I understand the
difficulty the difficult actions you've had to take for your
own comfort. I do not think I can truthfully and honestly look
at that and say that a large portion of that is my fault. But
I do understand that the mistake I made while small was the catalyst
for something far larger. I want you to know it's not your fault
either for feeling that way, for having those problems, that
underlying trauma. I've spent the past few days that just went
way louder than my other.
>> I've spent the last the past few days physically torturing
myself because I was upset at my own mind for not being able
to read a social situation. But it's not my fault. I'm like that.
I didn't choose to be like that. I didn't make the decision to
be. It just is.
This doesn't have to do with reading social cues. That's the
funniest part. That's not where heed up. The part where he up
was making anything was doing any kind of sex joke with a person
but that person had kind of thrown sex energy back at him in
a way like not overtly but they're both operating on basically
the same level like if you knew none of the labels that conversation
was totally normal. The the problem and they were both reading
cues perfectly normally. The problem is the preconceived notions
or what they knew before that conversation that might make that
conversation inappropriate. So it's nothing to do with autism.
It's like the opposite of autism. I would expect somebody with
autism to understand those labels and more rigidly act in a certain
situation.
>> So, it's weird that they're just offputting it offsetting
it on to being a
that seems inappropriate.
>> Jesus. But I think it's really important that someone
tells you and reaffirms you that you're what you're going through
isn't your fault. You didn't choose this for yourself. Yes, what
I said was wrong. I know it's difficult to process that I can
make mistakes, especially knowing how you looked up to me, but
I can. I'm also human. Oh, this is a weird angle to take. Listen,
I know that you thought I would couldn't make mistakes. I know
you thought I was perfect. I get it. I do get it. I really do.
I basically am perfect. But you have to understand that I am
human, too, and I can make mistakes.
I forgive you for thinking that, but I I can make mistakes. And
you should understand that. You should know that. You should
be okay with that. >> Weird. weird.
uh I'm also human. I am also human, too. I know processing that
is difficult, especially when you're the type of person that
jumps to blaming themselves first before all others. I'm like
that, too. You know I am. We've talked about it many times. You
didn't do anything wrong. And I had no idea what kind of powder
cake was lurking under the surface. I know it must be agonizing
to have that be surfaced by a frankly pretty innocuous joke.
I mentioned having a panic attack early in that day. You know
what caused it? Not anything that should have been stressful.
Nothing like that. No, it was someone joking about a Google doc.
Dude, this guy's got this guy's got all kinds of ghosts in his
head while he's having this
>> Yeah, Greater Sam. This is This is like It's the preconceived
notions going to the convo. Yes. >> But dude, he I uh I
I called this a little bit earlier. Yeah, he did something up
not to this person, but to other people. And he is very scared
about those other people doing something. He He did something
tangible. He did something that's actually bad and he's like,
"Oh, this person who's like freaking out of me for nothing. I
have to convince them they're freaking out on me for nothing
because if I don't, I'll actually be in trouble. I'll actually
get [__] hooked."
Very funny. Very, very, very funny.
>> All right. But God, it felt like I was right back there
again. Terrified that people are going to try to ruin my life
with falsehoods because I made a group of people angry one time
because of a video game. It was that exact same feeling again.
It was like I was right back there. I like I never left. Trauma
is incredibly incredibly scary. I know what it's like. I don't
know what it's like to experience that with.
But I do have serious wounds that are still scars to this day.
It's not your fault that you have felt these things. Uh you did
not choose to do this yourself. It is not fair. It is not fair
to anyone. Forgive me if I've said too much, but I know you're
hurting. I just want you to know you're not alone and that it
isn't your fault. It's okay. It's just a lot. I'm sorry. I I'm
not really going through all of her statements here because like
listen, I can just read the DMs. I don't need to like double
speak on the DMs, okay? Oh, but hold on. I can actually do this
to satisfy my own ego and show that like this isn't really going
to work, right? That like I I can see how she'll receive a lot
of this. It's all the stuff. It's all the me me stuff, right?
They repeatedly made it a point to state how I knew how trusted
was when it came to these things. They made out like I was accusing
them of repeated behavior of the sort, getting extremely defensive
and treating me like I was making a big deal out of nothing.
I felt crazy. They made me feel crazy. It became even more defensive,
excusing their behavior is understandable because of the group
dynamic. I tried to point out that the this was a problem within
itself. That the group dynamic was getting to a point where people
involved with or witnessing interactions that made them uncomfortable
when they didn't want to. They got upset at me for implying there
was a pattern and that this was one time mistake that won't happen
again. In hindsight, I think we all understand now that that
was a complete lie. Fate continues that they have continued to
work on themselves over the past year, accidentally revealing
that this that is this is something they know is a problem that
needs fixing. They continue to paint it as a onetime mistake
to me again, saying how much it hurt them, comparing what I said
to something someone would say about an abuser again. They talk
about how badly it affects them, how it's a onetime mistake again.
Bro, I can just I can tell, man. This is
unlucky. Shay then mentioned someone joking about a Google doc
to my face, which painful irony, I know. It honestly feels like
they were taunting me with a reminder of their trauma, but this
time about this situation getting out to the public. It was not
necessarily to tell me this information whatsoever, but they
continued nonetheless, telling me how afraid they were of their
life being ruined by falsehoods.
This is very funny. Okay, you don't need to apologize. It's okay.
Just know I sympathize greatly and that it really sucks badly
when a triggering I really wish this word wouldn't have been
me'd into oblivion because I mean it genuinely phrase or experience
comes from a place that should be comforting. Just a conversation
with a friend. That joke that had me spiraling that day, it was
from a friend of mine, too. Maybe it hurts even more when it
happens from a place we trust because we let our guards down
and don't expect something like that to materialize out of thin
[__] air. Rationalizing the reality of the situation
feels possible in the moment. Trauma sucks. It does. Yeah.
Not sure if you want to hear this from me, but I am older than
and have been through this for a long time. But it does get better.
There was an analogy I saw one time. A rubber ball inside a square
bouncing around forever. One spot on one of the walls is a button
that triggers a traumatic experience. The ball doesn't ever really
go away, but over time it shrinks. And while it will still sometimes
hit that button, the frequency of that happening decreases and
continues to decrease.
The more we come to terms with what happened that where the trauma
is rooted, why it is there, I hope this makes sense. It helped
me to picture it that way. It gives me some hope. Maybe we can
give you some some too. I know that hope's in short supply these
days. I appreciate it. I think though I think I need more space
now. I understand. Hey, before you do anything, I will give you
that space. I promise. But can you please leave me unblocked?
I just hm stupid slip up that I made got you into deep and I
feel like at least I want to be available to do anything I can
help with that or I can to help with that. I just care about
you so much. You're someone I incredibly highly value and I'd
like to at least feel like I'm doing something to help. Even
if that's literally nothing, I just don't want to be in isolation.
I'll understand either way you choose.
I didn't say it also, but no hard feelings about me from this
genuine misunderstanding. No big deal. Oh, hold on. What was
that? It's my bad. Where do we see this? I don't even see that
in her messages.
>> The one he's first responding to. I don't see that.
Where is this?
>> Okay, that's my bad then. I'm sorry. I'm just extremely
jarring. It's just just extremely jarring to see, especially
since I don't remember that. That's my fault then.
What was that about? We go from 145 to
I appreciate it. Now I need more space. I can't see when this
is from, but you probably read it. I'm fine with leaving you
unblocked.
I was planning on saying I'd be fine leaving you unblocked anyways.
Though I do need my space right now, so please don't message
me. I appreciate it. Okay, we're going down to 56 now.
The name Oh, hold on. Before the name drop and why Shay was banned
actually ended up reblocking them soon after. They didn't know
this until right now. Sorry. This is because since that conversation
happened, I had heard of more people's experiences. At this point,
the entire thing left a bad taste in my mouth and I was sick
of making exceptions. But it was but it was hearing about what
Shade had told people behind the scenes that really cemented
to me that there was someone I would never wish to speak to ever
again. I had learned this through Redacted 2 who had been messaged
by Shay and told what happened. Shay's message as I mentioned
prior was this one. It's the one where he says I feel like it's
unreasonable to blame me for that. They the lie in that the joke
was in the caliber of God I wish that were me. That is simply
not true. Like I said before it was plainly written as as so
when am I getting this though? It's Where's my hug? He's asking.
It's not a demand. Don't call it a demand.
>> I had received this information after being contacted
by someone who had also been affected by Sha's previous actions.
Anonymous number six on September 11th, 2025. Oh god, never forget.
Sheay will never forget. This is when I learned how far back
Sheay's actions have gone. It spans several years, over 5 years
to be specific. The person in question was aware that Sheay had
messaged redacted
about or sorry what had happened and pieced together that me
leaving a group, the same group she was about to be banned from,
was a result of Sheay making me uncomfortable. This was something
that Redacted 2 actually tried to reach out to me to figure out.
But because it was a general question as to why I left, I tried
to conceal what had happened out of fear Redacted 2 would tell
Shay.
I'd assumed that both of them are really closed for some reason.
After a lot of talking on the 12th of September, Shay was banned
from that group. said group was told about what happened and
my identity was kept anonymous as advised.
It was for my safety on the slim chance if it were to ever leak.
Originally, screen caps were censored heavily to avoid any sort
of revealing my identity. Then the problem was that entrusted
Sheay was responding to the ban in real time in the vent channel.
Then this is when my name was dropped. Oh, he talks about her.
Uh-oh.
I just can't believe that. I'm sorry. I can't believe I'm worth
knowing or being friends with. Not when I keep hurting up and
hurting people. Why do you think Blank left weeks ago? Oh, this
is the we already looked at this one. Yeah. Okay.
And this was the what she says is abusive about the art from
the year
All my friends, everyone both within the group they were banned
from, a lot of which were also entrusted and outside the group
entrusted now knew I was involved in this in this involved in
this. People in the vent chat started to talk about me and because
of how Shape had presented the situation to people both in chat
and in private. They were defending Shay and making out like
I was being unreasonable. As soon as this happened, I was told
by people it was up and wrong, so they told me. It was mortifying
and to watch people I cared about talk about me like that was
soul crushing. Shay has now since deleted the message that name
drops me or edited it out.
Now I feel obligated to come forward to the group that Sha Shay
was banned from. They already knew I was a big part in this,
so I had absolutely nothing to lose. It was scary. I didn't Oh
my god. Just yapping.
Holy [__] Holy sh I can now confirm that Ocean Bagel
looked over the first accountability post and Willie J. Willy
Jay looked over both accountability posts. Both of them have
helped mediate the situation. I am thankful for all the work
they've done for us all.
Holy.
okay. Now, I felt obligated to come forward. I have to keep reading
because it's all relevant.
Whether it was small interactions that seemed off or continued
weird behavior that spanned long passages of passages of time,
people now felt confident enough to share their own experiences
with Shay because they knew they weren't the only one. It was
weirdly healing. Oh, wait. Was it her first? Oh god, it was her
Bro, I think I think this guy
thought he could keep this woman quiet. He knew other stuff was
coming out and he um Yeah, he thought he could keep her quiet
or something.
I That seems like what's going on here. I don't know cuz I I
think there's got to be other things that are a big deal cuz
this one to me as much as like I could understand that he's like
an he's not very understanding of other or considerate of other
people. I don't think this is cancel worthy at all. Maybe it
is in this community or something. He certainly acted like it
was but
anyway I think the first accountability post was this one. This
is like the first accountability post I think.
Yeah. Anyway, there was small interact.
shared full video evidence to the people in the group of the
first confrontation I had with Shay and understandably they were
disappointed. They already had the screen caps of other big two
the other two big incidents. So this was new to
Now we had a bigger problem. A lot of people had experiences
with Shay interacting with them flirtatiously. Additionally,
Sheay had just named dropped me and vented about their own behavior
to the responsive support from the friends from the rest of our
friends who didn't know what was going on. This was when other
people got involved and started to aid Shay in the process of
trying to make this right. working with both sides to gather
evidence and try to minimize the damage as much as possible.
She had two people look over the first statement, plus one person
look over their second. And personally, I don't think they would
have been as inclined to make it if these people hadn't been
working together. This is probably news to hear for you all for
all of you considering Sheay has made no note or reference to
the fact that they received help, support, and encouragement
in making that decision to make their own account accountability
posts. I believe that because it didn't seem like he believed
he was really that much in the wrong and other people sort he
got like yaslighted into accepting responsibility for something
he shouldn't have. That's what it looks like to me. He got totally
gaslighted. Okay. Not very often you see the the purported abuser
in a situation be the one who gets gaslighted, but it it happened
here. He got gaslighted into taking responsibility for he shouldn't
have. That's crazy.
Okay. Instead, they've phrased it as if they had done it all
on their own. I can now confirm Ocean Bagel looked over the first
and Willie Jay Willy Jay looked over both accountability posts.
Once we first once we were notified that Sheay was planning on
making an accountability post, we waited. The first accountability
post
on the 14th of September 2025, an accountability post was sent
entrusted that vaguely talked about how Shay had a handful of
interactions with friends that made them uncomfortable that were
in nature. 57. Oh, this is not it. Hold
at idiot. This is him coming out as fully ripped. Okay.
>> Okay. Hold on. Uh Jesus, there's a lot of reading. My
voice is getting [__] up. I was already sick and
now my voice is getting totally.
>> Holy [__]
Okay. Hey, I just want to talk about this with you guys here
and be open about it and make sure I'm taking proper accountability.
I've had a handful of interactions with closer friends of mine
in the past while that have in the past while that have left
them feeling uncomfortable. Specifically, conversations with
jokes and conversations that were in nature. Additionally, during
time at inerson events, I would occasionally misread social cues
and engage in physical activities, stuff like cuddling, nothing
explicit beyond that without always being crystal clear that
is it was comfortable and okay for the other person. I never
did any of this with malicious intentions by any means and it
still but it still caused them harm and still made them feel
uncomfortable and that's completely on me. I feel absolutely
horrible about it all. I had several concepts of interactions
internally normalized that just weren't normal for the vast majority
of people and even though I never meant to, I overstepped boundaries
and caused discomfort. I'm incredibly disappointed and angry
at myself that I did not realize sooner that I was failing to
comprehend boundaries. Over the past few weeks, I've been thinking
deeply about how I need to change completely change, sorry, how
I approach interactions. so that this doesn't happen again. If
I ever if I've ever made you feel uncomfortable with anything
I have said, I am deeply deeply sorry. I've already been up taking
steps or I have already been taking steps to make sure this does
not become a recurring issue. I will be starting up therapy attendance
again. I deleted my second private Twitter account as it was
only reinforcing negative feelings inside me about the whole
thing and only further normalizing an incorrect perspective of
interactions and close friendships. That's maybe the most introspective
thing I've seen. He's that's the Twitter account. I assume that
he posts like nudes on. Yeah, stop your friendships, weirdo.
Stop it. Okay. And in general, I have completely rethought about
how I interact with people close to me moving forward. I will
do better. I promise.
Oh, he touched people IRL. Well, there there were some cuddling
allegations IRL. Yes, there's one person who claims it's the
star person, I think. No, no, no. The uh Hold on. It's not the
star person. I need a third instance of this document. Give me
a second.
I'll get the name for you.
It is the Shut up.
It was the Aspen person. Oh, actually, Star Smiley and Aspen
both made assault
Um, I'm not sure about the Aspen one. I'm not totally sure. The
Star Smiley one was like that's his long-term partner who he
just apparently assaulted like 3 months ago in September or
So, there are some more serious things as well, but I'm touching
people. Yeah.
Uh, over the past few weeks, yeah, we already did all this. Uh,
I deleted my second private Twitter.
Changing. I have an incorrect perspective of how interactions
and close friendships and in general, I have completely rethought
how I interact with people close to me moving forward. I will
do better. I promise. That's what we call the first accountability
post for she says they'll do better. Uh it is a repeated thing
that they say have said to multiple people at this point. But
clearly Sheay has not done better enough to stop himself from
omitting information, repeatedly talking about how they feel
and about how they hurt people. Trauma dumping in what is supposed
to be situations where they are taking accountability and for
ways they hurt other people and telling outright lies or downplaying
what they did. Every single statement that has been made about
this situation by Sheay to all of you has had a pattern of self-loathing,
vagueness, and a pretty fake sense of how much Shay actively
wanted to make these posts. But we'll get to more in we'll get
more into that when I talk about their most recent second accountability
post. For transparency, this post was not sent to me by Sheay
or two people who saw it over before posting. This post was not
sent to me by Sheay or the two people who saw it over before
posting. I had to find out uh find this out through friends who
were there to see it themselves as soon as it was posted. It
was kind of horrifying to see people's reactions to this after
the fact, watching people I had grown to know just blindly support
Shay without full context. People made out that they were an
amazing person for doing below the bare minimum. It broke my
heart. I understand that people were hesitant to come up to me
about this and that it is difficult to ask someone who or ask
someone what happened because they feel it might not be their
place. But nobody came to me to ask what had happened directly
or to tell me what they were here for because uh because of this
situation. People were too scared to and in fact or and it made
me Oh, god damn it. The zoom is killing me. People were too scared
to to like I guess reach out to her and it made me feel so goddamn
alone. People around it entirely and the only support I got was
from pe from people who weren't in the know were vague check-ins
and even then it seems as if the reason they reached out wasn't
explicitly because of the Shay stuff. They just wanted to in
general. It broke me and I've lost a lot of trust in people as
a result. Since then, I've told a couple of people what happened,
but I also hid it from others because I was afraid. By the way,
just to be transparent, they mentioned their second alt here.
While I followed their first alt, I never at any point attempted
to follow their second alt before it was deleted. You can probably
understand why for very, very, very obvious reasons. Those obvious
reasons being I'm Arows and I don't want to see their suggestive
photos. That seems fine.
Second confrontation.
Originally, before the first accountability post dropped, I had
planned to have a voice call with Shay, but it felt fell through
due to my lack of trust in them. Then I had decided to go through
one of the people who had helped look over the accountability
post to a second to send a second final message to them. But
I got impatient, unblocked Shay, and sent it directly to them
and said on September 16th, 2025. I cannot post the entire message
through a screenshot considering it was around 2,700 words long.
You don't say. Oh, she was wordy. You don't say. No way. No shot.
This person, no.
My god.
Jay was now properly aware of two major Oh, hold on.
Uh, do not feel inclined to read the entire thing if you don't
want to. It goes over a lot of this stuff. I've already gone
over here just less structured. Most important thing is this
message. You have seen as a screen cap uh at the top of this
written statement as in bold and is in bold plus highlighted.
Sheay has now was now properly aware of the two major events
that occurred that triggered my want to cut myself off from them.
There is no excuse left for any misunderstandings of events.
Sheay says it literally exactly himself at the end of the first
blocks of messages. once again saying I have made I have made
no excuses. I will be better. Remember this Shay once again was
writing a lot and it's taken it's a okay hold on we got to go
look at these screenshots. Hold on.
So this is 59. Okay.
We don't have 58. We don't have 58 is gone. There's no 58.
58 has been deleted. Where did 58 go?
We don't have a 58.
I can't backspace it. 58's just removed.
That's [__] up, dude. Okay. All right. These past
few weeks, and especially these past few days, have been incredibly
sobering for me. I frankly did truly did not realize the impact
of things I was saying. You're completely right. I want you to
Dude, I can't I I might have to tap. I might have to tap. I think
I'm I'm basically done, dude. I don't think
this is a lot. Holy [__]
I'm trying to get through one post,
I might have to tap out. This is like a lot. A lot. A lot. A
lot. I don't know if I can.
>> I'm sorry, dude. There has to be like way better stuff
than this, too. And I just don't know if I can do it. There's
like so much.
>> Is she guilty? I don't even know. I just started reading
this, dude.
Holy [__]
>> bro. I had um
man, there's like politics stuff I got to watch. I got to watch
Fentes on Rumble talk about Marjgery Taylor Green. But what did
happen to 582? I don't know. I I literally don't know, dude.
It's like late and like it's late. It's very late. Okay. I just
wanted to commit to being here like longer tonight because I
have been taking a lot of time off. Okay.
57 58 59. Anyway,
if that's the story. I don't know if it's the story. I'll be
honest though. I gota
I had a jet nine hour stream. All right. Going to start being
more consistent. I think
it's not even that late. It's pretty late.
It's pretty late. I started a little late today.
Should be able to get started a little sooner. I'm probably not
going to continue this. Honestly, this seemed like
Honestly, it just seems kind of like this meandered super hard.
I could tell it was meandering. I even cut off. I didn't even
keep reading this. I just went back to only reading the DMs.
But holy [__] there's so many DMs. There's just so
much here.
Holy sh I did not I bit off way more than I could chew. I didn't
realize how much was here. Okay, cuz I swear to God, I looked
at Chud I think I turned on Chud's stream this morning or I looked
at his title and his title was like, I read this dog. He said
something like he read this document on his kickstream. I'm like,
"Okay, so it can't be that long." And now like 5 hours later,
here we are. We're not even through the the second allegation
out of 19. These other ones have to be short, right? Yeah. These
other ones are just really short. These other ones are one pagers.
This isn't quite a one pager, but this might be worth going through.
Honestly, I just think I think this was a bad one to be on. And
I kind of knew this was a bad one to be on because it had a table
of contents. Okay. Chud read it for eight hours, then did a brief
a brief thoughts stream. Oh, I see. So, he read it for a long
time on kick. Okay. Maybe we'll maybe we'll think about reading
the rest of it tomorrow. Okay. To be honest, I think I can sum
up the first one. The first one has so much repeat
I'll be honest. It's just got so so much repeat information.
I'm like actually interested,
but I just think reading everything this person wrote is just
a lot. I'll be real.
There's like a lot of here. I feel like if I could summarize
it a little better, it would be better, right?
That's what I need to be able to do. I learned a lot about reading
these documents and then we basically didn't have like a review
forever and I just haven't had a chance to implement some of
the stuff I knew.
I'm not going to have chat GPD summarize it. That's lazy. No
shot. Nope. I need to read it myself and I will keep reading
it at some point here. Okay. I didn't realize how much there
was to get through. You know what? [__] it. I think
tomorrow I'm I'm coming back tomorrow. I'll have a summary of
this one of the first one. Okay.
I will do a summary of it and then we will continue reading.
I think we'll see. But I think so. I think we'll actually continue
reading because I think the rest of it's probably reasonable,
right? I think so. Okay. All right. I love you guys.
Be back
Thanks everyone for being here. We're back. We're streaming.
We're doing things. Doing big things. Okay, have a good night.
>> Starts with a haik coup. It does start with a ha coup.
Jesus Christ. Okay. All right. We'll talk to you guys tomorrow.
Bye. Good night.